are you out of your mind here's the
debate
you're upset
[Music]
and we are live okay fantastic folks we
are here episode number 148 i've been
looking forward to podcast for a while
we've been out this entire week i've
been in orlando but we got a special one
for you today with
obviously adam sausage but we got vinnie
vincent oshana assyrian comedian former
marine we got them no air force air
force my apology it's okay but i'm not
like the movie nicer
nicer rooms you guys don't exercise yeah
you chose to exercise yeah but it was a
mandatory yeah exactly and then we also
have
tony hinchcliffe here
tony the the
legendary hinchcliffe i i i wasn't what
was it jacksonville yeah and i was up
there with uh uh yourself rogan hans we
had a great time by the way
what a night it was and i'm listening to
you perform can i tell him one of your
jokes or no sure i'm gonna tell one of
your jokes so he says uh
you know the other day i got a friend of
mine that called and he was very
concerned he was concerned about uh
his kid i said what's going on he says i
just found out we're having a baby i
said that's goodness congratulations to
you says yeah but
it's some bad news because we're having
a girl
he says why are you upstairs because i
wanted a boy he says don't worry
nowadays she may change your mind
exactly nowadays you still got a chance
yeah
i'm shocked people are still having
gender revealed it's like who are you to
say what it is yet yeah how dare you the
parents as the parent how dare you
say that it's a boy or girl you have to
give it a chance well listen cool thing
about that joke by the way i'll jump in
is that that's a true like beat for beat
that was a real thing we were at dinner
and it just happened just like that and
i go nowadays you still got to change
you have to use it yeah so do you in
that moment say this is
material yep that's actually like my
writing process is i just wait until i
say something that makes everybody like
slam the table at the right time and
then that's it well there was there was
a couple moments because i noticed
everybody was dropping jokes during
dinner yeah and then joe was very quick
to say yeah that's not funny right yeah
yeah that's that's what we do live and
the relationship was everyone looking at
joe like all right was that good was
that okay is joe the the seeking
approval like mentor big brother not the
dinner table not to the people that he's
friends with you know but the people who
it's their first time hanging out with
them that's always interesting right you
guys go back 20 you guys go back a long
time a really long time uh we've been
doing the road together for over a
decade so like that's a lot airplane
rides and dinners and green rooms and
shows so who's part of that crew that's
been on the road together with you rogan
who else well i mean rogan's crew is
famously like a bunch of badasses like
it's really really comedians a lot of
the comedians at joe's level don't take
uh you know
real real real hard hitters with them
they're a little bit afraid that they
might get buried you know what i mean
but he famously i mean joey diaz re
shafir duncan schrussel bert kreischer
thompson
all these guys are now yeah super super
top of the food chain
um have all been part of that theo part
of that crew or no
i think yeah i mean yeah we're all
comedy store brothers but he he i think
he's only opened for rogan a couple
times on the road yeah so that's the
rogan crew yeah yeah but to have
headliners wrote like that hard hitters
opening for you says a lot about who you
are as a comic because like he said you
want funny people you don't want the
show to suck but to have hit or hit her
because you know the show climbs and if
it's just if joe doesn't step up then
it's just it's horrible so obviously
right and if it's climbing by the time
that it's to me then you know it's on
yeah
how did you get into it how did you get
into account obviously during you know i
ask you but for people that don't know
how to get into it i mean like most kids
i had i had a perfect perfect regimen of
a childhood to set me up for being a
comedian really really dangerous
neighborhood different diverse uh
neighborhood very dangerous at the time
um
single mom
uh dad you know crazy story with the dad
you know everything just uh teachers
were mean you know i was looking for any
type of like love or respect from people
and uh getting laughs from kids in class
back then was uh was everything it
brought me like a certain amount of joy
and i would get in trouble and
you know they would tell my mom tony
messed up again i'd be grounded and then
i would you know once i get once i got
back i just couldn't stop i couldn't
stop making people laugh and the
teachers told my mom at a young age like
he's never going to really
fit in with society like he's not going
to be able to work a normal job and it
stressed her out you know i was her last
kid a fi the fifth kid
everybody else was already in college i
had much older siblings like it's just a
perfect little recipe for the four above
you boy what's the
my brother's 12 years older than me a
sister 14 a brother 16 years older than
me and a sister 20 years ago two and two
yeah that's cool well there's that big
of an agency so you're the baby baby
baby yeah it's a crazy crazy story yeah
and you guys are both comedians did you
guys both know that you were going to be
comedians like when you were kids like
sounds like you had a perfect childhood
of like
this kid ain't going to make it in the
real world right you know comedy is kind
of going to be for him
same story for both of you or what yeah
i got i was
i can't tell you how many times i got in
trouble where my parents had to come in
you know having middle eastern parents
it was like sitting and listening to
everything that i did and then and my
mom's like okay my father's like wait
once we walk into the house watch what's
gonna happen to you so i would just
watch like my father watch george carlin
and all those i would just memorize that
and he would make me act it out in front
of like my father would drink and he'd
like vinita he'd bring me in the middle
of a room and be like just go and i
would just do carlin's whole set swear
to god and they're just laughing died
laughing and drinking
i just knew it and then in the military
i was just you know getting in trouble
the first day the first day and you
already know that's the way they shake
you down i got in trouble on that day
just trying to be a funny person it was
over tony let me ask you
you know how uh
in mixed martial arts there's different
form of art right you got you know jiu
jitsu taekwondo
you know all these different ways you
can go and they said this guy's
background is wrestling again kobe knows
how to wrestle but stand up game is
going to be tough going up against xyz
is there different kind of art and
comedy like insult comedy this comedy
what different kind of comedy is there
100
a lot of uh you know um i mean insult
comedy is just one aspect of it but like
what really i think what it is for using
mma as an analogy is it's like you know
some guys can do everything in some
fights they'll do
wrestling and surprise you sort of and
some people even though it's like you
know nate diaz is like a what a double
black belt like highest level jiu jitsu
guy you don't want to be stuck on top of
him right but meanwhile you look at him
and he's slapping around
conor mcgregor out boxing conor mcgregor
who boxed
with floyd mayweather you know what i
mean it's like uh anyway my point is is
a lot of comedians i think stick to an
act like a very set act and some of them
uh
are more loose anything can happen
you're making major adjustments to what
show is in front of you right then
at that moment and the ones that can
make those adjustments which is like a
real you know comedy store type of trait
uh
the ones that are really good at that
can
decide to improvise for the entire
hour-long setup that's what they're
feeling that night and that's fun
whereas a lot of comedians would panic
in that situation because they didn't
work on that and they didn't take those
chances late at night and get really
really really good at that and
trusting your instincts and whatnot
would you say oh go ahead is it is it
similar to
is it similar to like
creating a crew and then you know how
we're having dinner and uh uh who was
with us we're having dinner first dinner
we had uh we had a couple guys with us
that were fighters yeah guy with the
best highlight ever ever yeah but
bradley is it uh with the fence kick guy
not defense kick guy no no they're both
studs by the way one of them just he
just got into ufc he's doing his first
fight but the other guy you would know
exact bradley i want to say
anyways he has one kick remember the guy
that kicks he holds his leg yeah and
then he's flipped around
knocks him out i know he's a fantastic
guy yeah anyways we're having this
conversation and he says well his
training camp is from michigan yeah they
train in michigan right and then such as
a training camp is here this person is
training campus here
does comedy also have a you know crew
that goes together and you kind of like
one guy's at the front lifting the other
three four five up is that kind of how
it works totally i mean because it's
it's
if it's working
perfectly then it's that on many levels
you know what i mean like the guy that
you met that weekend hans kim that was
his first ever arena that he's ever done
and he's a regular on my podcast
as of only a few months ago like six
months ago he writes and performs a
brand new minute every single week but
he kept doing so good and stood out
to joe and then so joe let him open a
couple shows and he
you know completely destroyed so joe
adam opened more shows and now all of a
sudden he goes from sleeping in his car
just a few months ago even though he's
been doing it eight years he was that
committed that he just bought a van and
put a mattress inside and like organized
his entire life into this van
and uh and now i mean he's you know
right there he's he's at the big dance
doing it and i mean he killed at that
show which means he's going to be on the
next one and sure enough he was just on
wednesday we did a show and we did a
show on tuesday in austin to prepare for
it and hans opened that show but he
wasn't even scheduled for wednesday and
he did so good on tuesday that it's like
why don't you come join us tomorrow
night and joe put him on the manifest
made sure his manager got him a hotel
you know what i mean and so instead of
literally the next morning he's on a jet
to do another arena
because of how good he does and that's
really
that's like the rogan way you know what
i mean is just trying to he keeps people
around him that are that are that are
doing good you get rewarded for that not
for
kissing ass or schmoozing because as you
probably saw hans misses his face when
he's eating and there's like potatoes
everywhere he's a disaster off stage but
he gets on and you know that's what he
does now pat are you asking these
questions because i don't know if you
guys know this
that's that ready pat's uh pat's
thinking about there's a reason he's
kind of bringing more comedians back on
he's he's he's got some level of
interest in this pat do you have a type
of comedy that you identify with the
most i don't know i'm an amateur i have
no idea but i i uh
my whole style the whole valuetainment
is teaching through entertaining that's
been the style of uh i've noticed that
teaching through entertaining works so
meaning you have to come you have to
entertain make them laugh to retain to
get people to pay attention to you to
selling and sales
you know you can just go out there and
sell based on a hey here's what i have
here's a structure or you can sell
through
winning them over and building report
that building rapport and building
relationship
it has an element of comic to it you
know humor too that's why a lot of
comedians are either but you know
they do either you know storytelling or
a lot of comedians have also done sales
you know they've been in sales and it's
natural you get me to like you i'm like
dude i like this guy you know what i'll
buy from this guy so there is an element
of selling yeah you're paying comedy
yeah you're pitching all the time yeah
you're like pitching your jokes it's
like i'm selling my life my jokes to you
laugh you know what i mean that's the
payment as you laughing so let me see
this guys can you tell me if the net if
it's working or not we just had a glitch
with
i'm trying to see if if you can comment
if you can see us
and it's going good now message me
because we got comcast folks here and
i'm getting text message that's why i'm
looking on my phone
if you can tell me you can steadily hear
us now and it's fine we'll get right
into it is it much better now with the
service john mario can you guys shoot me
a text people are saying it's better
people are saying this better comments
yeah they're saying it's better okay
fantastic so let's get right into it by
the way someone's asking me a question
what is the shirt i'm wearing sure it
says
freewheel we have to talk about it
because this whole thing got started
we'll get into it maybe later on we got
to talk about disney we got stuff to
talk about with netflix we got to talk
about
twitter we got stuff that's going on in
florida right now with taxes and
obama spotify spotify dropped him
bloomberg says obama's left did spotify
drop obama's did obama drop spotify
nobody knows
and then there's cnn plus which crushed
it they they did so well
their launch is one of the greatest
launches of all time really they made so
much money that after two weeks they
said this is too much money can't shut
it down
i mean
seriously i just subscribed today things
are tough
we also got to talk about what's going
on i mean people are getting beat up
tyson on airplanes johnny
i mean
for tyson i'm assuming everybody here
saw tyson oh yeah with the video did you
see the video of the guy recording the
guy and he's like bothering him and the
other guy's laughing and it's like bro
there's only so many times you could
poke a bear to the bears and like all
right i'm gonna be dressed here's when
you what was your first reaction when
you watched when you started hitting him
i was just like i don't know how he got
because you know mike has these little
angles he was rocking that dude's face
oh my god what do you what did you think
about like what did you think about the
guy not tyson what did you think about
the guy trolling him like how did you
process him
i didn't get to hear what he was saying
like that's everything right do we know
what he was i said what he did can you
put up the video because i think we can
see the video it's not like you can say
yeah and tony he was saying something
about because the guy recording was like
he's bothering uh michael
there's a better video there's a video
that shows a side
about the video
because the guy's like the guy's like
laughing he's like hey he's bothering
mike tyson about shrooms and it's funny
and it's laughing and then dude it took
mike a while bro he he yeah that was
talking for a minute and he just did you
hear what he said pat
yeah the guy's like he's he's in mike
because they're look this is this is not
fair to show that video
they're not showing this clown trying to
clown tyson
that's what they're not showing all
they're showing is tyson beating up the
guy tyson's in his seat he's not doing
anything this guy's over him is this the
one yeah
make this one bigger oh yeah that's like
how much of that [ __ ] are you gonna take
oh yeah
go back go back a little bit yeah watch
this
oh this is great
how many seconds can you do that
tomorrow
trying to give us some shrooms trying to
give us some shrooms
well look he's trying to have his wallet
out he got his money out
he should have never gave you his money
peasants peasants
and then all of a sudden oh and then
guess what
show the next clip
[Music]
how much money is he going to make
how much money is he going to make turn
around look at that
oh dude how much money he's going to
make pat
think about that
think about how much money this this
i mean dude that i mean i don't know he
that guy you know
the thing that stands out to me is i'm
leaning over his
over tyson's seat
you know physically so
i don't think he got rocked yeah i mean
he got i think he got what he deserved
because of the uh
infiltration of his physical space i
think people punching each other for
saying something's bad but that guy was
physically annoying oh that may be it
makes me happy though finally it's like
people are just like but listen if
there's a famous quote on on internet
yeah the quote is yes everybody acts
tough until somebody punches you in the
face
exactly that's mike's quote yep so you
know what i like what dana white posted
did you see that's what they know white
post about it which is sick dana white
says this hey idiots look at this he
says hey dummies for your future for
future reference just move c doesn't
move that's so badass let me tell you
something i love this i'll tell you why
number one you know who feels bad for
this guy they got beat up
absolutely [ __ ] nobody nobody okay no
we met mike tyson you've you did an
hour-long interview with mike tyson in a
freaking boxing ring
in uh where were we in vegas mgm we're
in vegas and [ __ ] mgm yes
okay
you couldn't have asked for a more chill
out nicer guy remember when he wreaked
the weed he was of course he was smoking
weed before after during whatever yeah i
we went i said hey mike let's take a
picture let's put your hands up you know
he goes he goes man i'm trying to fight
you man put your hands down this shake
it's like as sweet as they come yeah do
you know what you end up you're not
telling the whole story though you're
not telling the whole story what's the
whole story he was so high i just said
that within five no no it was so
bad that within five minutes i was
asking for cheeto
i wanted to eat i'm like i can't do this
anymore
but the interview was fantastic he he
was great yeah and if you didn't know
who mike tyson was you said this guy is
a freaking pacifist yeah like you don't
other than the roy jones thing remember
the one line when he fought joy jones he
says like everyone feels bad about roy
jones like i haven't fought
yeah
just retired two years ago and the guys
what's the one jim gray and he's like
you're freaking mike tyson everyone
expects you to course
yeah and look this guy got what he paid
for but you're talking [ __ ] to mike
tyson in an enclosed
capsule in the sky enjoy your [ __ ]
but i guarantee you he's going to make
he's going to make a lot of money that
guy i don't know
why because all right ready for this
yeah i feel you about the space just
like any man like no i would have
punched him one hundred percent i don't
care who the person is but mike is
sitting down the guy yeah is talking
behind him but mike got up turned around
and physically assaulted a guy on an
airplane i and i'm with you guys he's
gonna sue and he's gonna make money i
guarantee you oh you mean that way you
mean through a loss
oh yeah maybe the air i don't know i
mean he can't probably can't do the
airline but
you yeah you could talk all the [ __ ]
that you want mike tyson who has money
beat the [ __ ] out of the guy trust me
he's going to get a lawsuit he's going
to use the billy madison defense 100
that's assault brother
[Music]
i've had many experiences i just did the
lab factory tone like about two three
weeks ago and i i adore mike tyson bro
he i look and it's chocolate sundaes and
he's sitting right there and i was just
like oh [ __ ] i was just about to do that
joke like not even a joke but i was like
in la like a week before mike tyson was
at a comedy show and some guy pulled out
a gun on the host and and the guy's like
hey look in front of mike and mike just
went come here and the guy was like i
love your mic and hug mike with a gun
wow i love you guys you guys saw that no
it was a it was a [ __ ] it was crazy mike
tyson is so amazing and so mike the guy
was like i just love you i hugged him he
hugged mike and then he left with a gun
the thing with mike tyson is most many
athletes many fighters especially
don't have a second act no right like
you guys can do comedy and like to your
freaking don rickles until you're 90
freaking years old you can do comedy
fighters don't really have a second act
mike tyson has reinvented himself 100 as
this like lovable huggable character
actor everything yeah everything i mean
the hangovers a lot of it yeah big time
speaking doing interviews with
everything doing the hot boxing what was
the thing that uh you said that he did
recently hot boxing with uh francis
nagano yeah i talked about it
he's turned into like he went from the
baddest [ __ ] on the planet yeah
to like the most lovable nicest guy he's
because he's always high and exactly and
we just got to remember yeah you know
he's still he's a [ __ ] beast yep oh
this is it this is you guys saw this
yeah and then like he literally hugged
look at mike mike's like come here do a
gun was drawn and mike tyson didn't even
stand up look he's like come here man
give me a hug you armed son of a [ __ ]
yeah
it's crazy
this is the same room that i saw another
video
yeah
this is not the this is in hollywood bro
next to roscoe's and chicken and waffles
you know you know what i'm talking about
they need to stop they show immediately
this is the second clip out of that
venue that i've seen in three days yeah
100 i know you're talking about two can
i ask you yeah
you guys as comedians i mean i don't
know which direction we're going here is
that is that
you know with chris rock getting
assaulted on stage by will smith you
brought up will smith will yeah
you know
as a comedian is this a concern of yours
that someone coming up and you're an
insult comic family if you look at your
wikipedia i'm not sure if you've seen it
recently bro you're known as an insult
comic no doubt is this something that
you are even more concerned about these
days is what schmucks in the audience
just walking up non-wheelchair
you know what i'm concerned with is not
anything physical it's the recording of
sets putting things out out of context
100
uh
you know that's the new scum of the
earth to me yes people it's that guy
that got punched by tyson is obviously
now that i didn't even know there was
that second angle of him playing to his
buddy
yeah he's saying film me exactly this
yeah and this is the weird world that we
live in
what what will smith did was will smith
being you know mentally unhealthy
blatantly a victim of whatever jade is
putting yeah well i mean you're talking
about but i'm not afraid of physical
things what bothers me is people
recording sets and the potential of
putting those out without context the
potential of sending it through an
editing bay and turning down the volume
of laughter in a situation yeah uh of a
live show tony i mean people do that
messing with clips
what happened to me the guy that wanted
to get famous from it in an interview
because he did so many interviews yeah
uh admitted he ended up admitting
publicly that he edited the video and he
decided when he was going to release it
which isn't even completely true because
the chinese government accidentally
released it before he woke up the day
that he was supposed to there's
something so talk about that what
happened with that well i woke up that
morning and uh
it was what's weird is i had a crazy
like
crazy like nightmare that woke me up at
like 5 a.m which is a rare thing in
itself and it was weird had my childhood
home in it it was just a weird morning
and i roll over you know how sometimes
you don't really want to look at your
phone you're just making sure nothing
crazy is happening
and sure enough
i was just awake enough to make it from
my text messages from my email to
twitter i'm like i'll check twitter real
quick yeah and that like minute like a
few minutes before someone's like you
all of these like out of
like not making sense tweets racist you
you racist
up
[ __ ] and i'm like wait what and it's
like career done dork loser and i'm like
what does what is this what happened
so i end up clicking on one of the
tweets and clicking on the person's
profile right to see what
maybe there's a tweet that they had from
minutes before and it was the video that
was that ended up being released by him
the one that supposedly went viral
hours later with english subtitles but
this was
um the same exact video with chinese
subtitles colored the exact same as the
video that he edited and put out yeah so
he made a version with english subtitles
and chinese subtitles
sent the chinese subtitles to the
chinese whoever news government there's
no difference between the two as we know
and they released it first he must have
slept in uh
but maybe drank too much the night
before had a night because he ended up
not posting his thing until 11 a.m
meanwhile it was coming out of china at
5am and i have screenshots to prove all
of that you know what i mean because i'm
literally like
what is this crazy
chinese video of my set it's a workout
set from last thursday i did an entire
weekend of shows hour-long sets in other
cities that weekend somewhere else like
i'm like why is my workout set my
riffing where i try new things and take
major chances at a comfortable home club
in my home city yeah like why is this
even out there and um
then i realized at 11 a.m when he posts
this is what happened to me happy asian
heritage month tony hinchcliffe did this
to me
uh
and he hashtagged like all of these
asian awareness asian hate things what
happened to you the next day like what
happened career-wise did that help you
did that hurt you
at the time at the very very time it
hurt me like immediately because uh i
mean
at the time the every news source is
drag is is
basically telling the wrong a wrong side
of the story and immediately you're like
how do i handle this and there's ways
right yeah so half of your friends are
saying uh whatever you do don't
apologize the other half are like you
have to apologize one half is like you
need to just give an explanation of what
happened i can't believe this guy did
this to you well you're in assault i'm
curious what is the publicist i have a i
had a manager a lawyer
uh i don't exactly have a publicist but
my lawyer called me immediately and he's
like you need to talk to i have on the
other line i'm patching you in with the
biggest crisis management uh lawyer uh
professional right now i'm patching him
in i'm like okay i'm gonna hear what
this guy has to say yeah all right and
this [ __ ] guy let me tell you what
being cancelled is like this [ __ ] guy
knows what he's doing and probably does
this all the time right he's like i know
what you're going through tony and i'm
gonna save you you have to give me 15
000 now and then you'll give me 15 000
tomorrow when you see results and then
if things are still bad you'll give me
another 15. on the third day
this guy just this guy's already at 50
000. this is already the biggest bill
for any employee that is he giving you
thus far like what is he saying that's
what's funny is he's got
nothing literally i'm literally like
what what can you do he's like well i
can get out ahead of this i can call the
news sources and make sure that they
don't post i go what if the news sources
don't even know about this yeah are you
going to inform them that this is a
breaking story you had no answer to that
i go what if what i go if i ignore this
completely isn't that the way to do it
and he goes well it's a that's a major
major risk could be the end but these
guys they're used to politicians they're
used to actors or none and actual crimes
mind you right not a comedian making fun
of another comedian at a comedy show
where they're warned beforehand you're
going to hear things that are out of
order recording is not allowed all of
these
aspects are in play so
these crisis lawyer crazy people are
used to dealing with politicians that
actually [ __ ] up yeah or people that
aren't comedians messing up i mean the
craziest part to me proof that news is
at its lowest point ever is that if you
googled me that day as a journalist
reporting on what you're seeing exactly
what you just said a few minutes ago is
true which is
my wikipedia and i think it's changed
since then i think it now says an
american comedian yeah but just scroll
down further before that literally when
this happened it said
tony hinchcliffe because i remember it
because tony hinchcliffe is an american
insult comedian that blah blah blah blah
blah yeah
right yeah it's changed now um
no you see right there
yeah but dude but it was originally
here's how crazy this is because i
remember it was originally the first
line right after birthday hinchcliffe is
an american insult comedian because i
always thought it was weird i'm like
american insult comedian what does this
even mean and did you ever think of
yourself as that or just yeah i'm a
comedian bro i'm a comedian yeah i talk
[ __ ] this is the only people that bring
up that i'm an insult comedian are the
people that read my wikipedia before i
come in and do a podcast
well look let's
let's address this head on yeah because
i look i used to do stand-up comedy many
years ago vinnie's extended comedian pat
is as great as storytellers it comes he
just hasn't been on stage yet yeah i had
heard of your name peripherally like
i've i've followed segura for years and
obviously rogan and i've heard of your
name i mean you know obscure stuff but i
wasn't like all right what does tony
stand for what do you talk about right
and then boom this thing
hit the atmosphere what i stand for is
exactly that type of insanity to where
either you're
either you're loving it or you're
pissed off because you don't know that
i'm doing what i strategically do like
that is my art form
is crazy ass
[ __ ] like to the
brim like not every comedian
what's crazy is that if it had been
a clean to an extreme we could say brian
regan or jim gaffigan if he did that
yeah that's crazy
let me ask you this let me ask you this
let me ask you this so what is today
in comedy what can't you touch because
like when i was watching hans do what he
was doing all he did is make fun of
asians but you can get away with it
because obviously he's and the jokes he
said by the way how many of them were
like crossing the line to the average
person every one of them right but he
can do it so because he's asian yeah no
because here's why
yeah let me ask the question then you
run it i want to hear from you because
you're so so what can't i touch
what can you touch what's gray area
what's super risky and who today can
touch anything and no one can say [ __ ]
about it right
so
the interesting thing and i'll go i'm
immediately going back because this is
the answer the reason why hans can do
that isn't because he's asian what's
interesting about what he's doing is
it's the fact that he's smiling big the
entire time he's likeable he's he's
putting the jokes on himself
oftentimes in a in a separation
even though maybe he's not a liberal you
know i'm not speaking for him but he'll
say i'm a liberal
so i
whatever i'm not gonna do his jokes but
he puts it on him instead of making fun
of women he'll go i'm like a woman i'm
his insecure you know what i mean
whatever he's making fun of everything
at once with a smile the art form the
art form is
getting it across and making it work
that's why another interesting thing
that happened you know with my
this is him yep he is asian almost every
picture though look at him what do you
notice
look at this
and that second one of course
people are idiots how they found that
one of him not smiling it's like
he is asian what do you mean
yeah okay so yeah well i mean that's
what i'm saying is that that's what i do
too is it's about it's about getting the
things across it's about making it work
if you're up there and you're literally
you know and that is to my to my own uh
judgment here like i'm sort of burying
myself because one thing that i didn't
do
in the video that got me in trouble was
smile a lot but it's because the reason
why i did what happened there was
because his whole thing before the five
minutes of his set before i went up was
white people are so mean and he was
doing things to try to get like not a
sympathy applause break but
not funny deep stuff like all that we
this this this and you're expecting a
joke and he basically goes like all we
want white people is for you to be nice
to us yeah and it's like i'm standing in
the back getting ready to go on and i
think to myself the funniest thing i
could do right now on a thursday night
where phones are supposed to be locked
up
uh it's my
show i'm the surprise on this show like
it's not my show my show i wasn't
headlining that show that was a workout
set on a show called a secret show it's
the secret show every thursday because
you don't know who's going to you're
dropping right i'm a drop in it's where
i work out stuff that i thought about
driving there or
yesterday in the shower or whatever it's
a place to take your time it's not your
type 20 you're just you're testing [ __ ]
out exactly and because he was going
white people are so mean white people
are so mean and then it's five minutes
of white people are so mean and at that
point i'm like i'm going to i'm going to
go 100 miles an hour here the funniest
thing i can do after his set and sure
enough again you know when when the
whole thing was breaking
what's his name from tmz harvey whoever
of course he took the interview this
this [ __ ] comedian that tried to do
this to me
and he took the interview and uh with
harvey and he even he goes all i heard
in that video was some laughter
and he goes well yeah but you should
have seen the looks on the people's
faces i'm like what what what what what
are we talking about here yeah so back
to pat's original question what's off
limits what's good nothing is off limits
if you can sell it if you can do it with
a smile and get a big laugh then
nothing's off limits it's about that
getting laughter period i definitely
think yeah he's right some people are
going to be offended but if you if you
if you have half the crowd dying of
laughter and the other half
that's amazing that's the that's the
love i forgot which special was uh with
louis ck
anybody could talk the hell with your
race you could talk about anything if
it's funny louis ck special tone i don't
know what the name of it but it was his
n-word joke where he's like he actually
says the full n-word life and he's it's
one of the most brilliant jokes where
he's like well white people got away
with saying the animal because when you
say the n-word you're making me say it
in my head he's like why don't you take
responsibility yeah and you say anything
bro you and nothing is off limits but
like you said you got to be
it has to be funny bro it has to be
something where people go oh [ __ ] like
he that's a great written joke so any
rate through the middle eastern i could
talk about anybody you know what i mean
anything anybody any race any situation
as long as it's personal to me if it's
funny bro people can laugh
i do a lot of the rooms that i do are
predominantly you know african-american
i talk about everything but there's
nothing that i don't talk about pat do
you ask that because you think that
there's certain things that should be
off limits there's certain things you
know that are universally funny like do
you have any strong opinions on like all
right this is certain things they're
completely off limits like talking like
for instance in in uh
ufc
uh what's the kid the guy's name we just
beat moss football colby covington talk
[ __ ] about dustin poury's wife and kids
like to me that is
i guess that's not off limits but that
is [ __ ] disgusting right but you know
free speech do what you want yeah but
that's different what what that that
does is there's if anybody laughs at
that you're like that yeah i don't know
if that makes sense or not like if if
you think that's funny when kobe says
what he says about dustin or he says
that about
jorge and he says that about all this
stuff
it's just a matter of time until
somebody
like
mazvidal found him in a restaurant and
he comes out and he gets into a fight
you can't say stuff you know i'm telling
you if he says that to the wrong ufc
armenian fighter yeah i'm telling you
it's over for that guy
like that to yeah you just cannot so set
that aside that to me is in a different
category of
um disrespect yeah i don't i don't know
where you want to put that and it's the
person that's doing it right a fighter
is one thing a politician saying
something is another thing like but a
comedian
we're supposed to be the ones that are
sort of a little bit responsible for
pushing the limits strategically there
is an article yeah but i think i think
you're you need to be free though that's
my concern yeah i think you need to be
free i think i'm concerned if you're not
free i look i run an insurance company
okay so we just had a convention we had
a few thousand people i've been in
orlando last few days
and we had a great time we made the
announcement on speakers by the way so
we have pen and tellers performance
we're shutting down mgm grant for a week
in august 15 000 people will have at
this event i'll have pen and teller open
up then i have nelly is going to be
performing sick putting on a concert we
have
kurt warner will be uh speaking then we
have
uh uh leila ali will be there as well
and last but not least you ready for
this one i'm ready shaq
after the kobe interview he blocked me
and messaged me pissed off because that
whole interview got 300 million views
and it was all over the place the same
thing you did with tyson or what do you
like the same kind of vibe we're going
to have a we'll see a conversation it
should be a good conversation because he
said that that's what this question you
have asked but but here's what i did let
me tell you what happened with me so i'm
coming up in business and i'm learning
from these advisors and mentors and the
rule of thumb in business is what never
talk religion never talk sex and never
talk uh uh politics right these are like
the three things whatever other things
that people want to add to it i'm like
you know what
um
i don't know i like talking religion i
like talking politics and i don't mind
talking about sex because at that time
i'm single so i'm like i'm dealing with
a bunch of young guys yeah hey they want
to talk about it talk about it right
and then you are smaller
so when you're smaller and you're doing
it the risk is higher
as you're getting bigger and you're
doing it you have a little bit more
credibility but it comes to a point
where you are managing expectation with
the audience and let me explain to what
i mean by this
first time i did a a interview with
michael francis and i did a mob
interview and then after that i then
reviewed 20 other mobsters and we did a
bunch of different things but the first
time i did it i can't believe pat did
this you should have never done this
you're an idiot you're this why would
you associate yourself and pop up i'm
like it's my show it's what i'm
interested in yeah if you're not don't
worry about it yeah exactly there's 50
million other channels that i started
interviewing bodybuilders why would a
business channel interview bodybuilders
why would you have on dorian yeah why
would you have on this person listen i
like bodybuilding you don't like it go
elsewhere yeah then i was in a so then
why is pat talking so much politics why
pat talking cia people why is pat
talking to communists this is a business
channel you shouldn't interview 10
communist professors and all these other
guys they hate america listen it's my
channel yeah so what i'm doing in that
moment with my fans my audience i'm
managing expectations
this is what i like you like it great
you don't you don't like it i think in
business like yesterday i'm giving a
message the whole message i gave
yesterday at the closing session was
about politics yeah and then the story i
told i told the following story i said
when 9 11 happened
and uh everybody is looking around
saying wait a minute two planes that's
the enemy are you kidding me no problem
what are you black you're white i don't
care where's your kid i'm gonna go help
you yep you're republican you're a
democrat i don't give a [ __ ] if you're
republican or democrat today we're all
americans right what happened the last
two years with kovit is
we said kovitt came and
say china's the one that caused a lot of
this rather than saying that's the enemy
we said you're a republican before i'm
an american i'm a democrat before i'm an
american we forgot the fact that we're
americans first before we're political
issues now
ten years ago twelve years ago i had
dinner with george one and i first
talked politics
people said you shouldn't talk about
that
and i'm like so i was a little bit on
edge myself yeah man maybe i shouldn't
talk about this in business because i'm
losing people right
and then eventually i said
five years i'm asking myself i can't
stop talking about this stuff this is
all i think about so my managing of
expectation with the audience was this
is what i talk about if you're
uncomfortable you can go to another
company of course but this is my comfort
zone so i think as a comedian
you are essentially
you know because you you can get lost
and seeing one guy goes viral as a
community like maybe i should try that
guy selling one guys on maybe i should
no you're like dude that's just not my
style yep this is my style what do you
want me to do and then you stick to it
and you manage that expectation with
your audience 100
and that's why none i didn't lose a
single fan during that entire thing
without a doubt everyone knows that
that's my thing so when when people come
and see me live if i don't have
something that's
you know
really put really pushing the limit uh
that's then they're not getting they
feel like you treated them yeah they're
like what are you doing bro you push the
limit all we did was laugh the whole
time meanwhile i need to get them to
literally go oh
god
that's all i did when i was listening to
you yeah i'm telling you i was listening
i'm like freaking hey this guy's
unbelievable i love if you haven't been
have you have you seen us uh not live
i've seen it as obviously i i thought i
thought i thought tony's message
was unreal hans was third you came right
before uh
joe and then joe came up and joe did
what joe did yeah but uh dude you were
just going like this you were going like
this and it's funny watching you how you
handled at first one of the mics wasn't
working they brought the new mic and
you're just in control you're dressed in
your you know thing that you haven't you
did what you did but
again i want
you to be free yeah you know i want
comedians to be free i want a comedian
to offend me go ahead and say something
middle eastern armenian say something
okay i want to hear it but but it better
be funny let me make me laugh what's my
balls but i think that's what you guys
are saying that in your world if you can
make it funny 100 yeah well let me let
me ask you guys tony yeah sorry well i
mean look i think comedians have a very
necessary role in society especially
right now in america today i think
as far as we talked about this the whole
conversation basically started on i
remember when i almost got canceled
right so we're talking about cancer
culture right now comedians have a
longer leash than any other person in
america whether you're a business person
ceo whether you're a politician whether
you're just average joe show on the
street comedians have that ability to
say
i could push the envelope i can push the
limit here look at from you know lenny
bruce yep who got cancelled yeah get
thrown in jail yeah to carlin
you know who turned from basically from
a comedian to the philosopher's head to
a modern day pundit even and then you
have um
richard pryor and everything that he was
doing eddie murphy but like these days
right now
uh louis ck got [ __ ] cancelled yeah
for doing something not even a joke some
some other stuff some other stuff yeah
okay yeah he got swept up in the me too
movement yeah okay but he got cancelled
by
hollywood though correct totally
different but then he's selling his own
specials and selling outside
one of the best in the world there's a
there's a reason he's not headlining
like he was before but here's my point
but he is here's my point okay
dave chappelle they tried to cancel dave
chappelle right yeah whether you believe
that or not like they tried to cancel
[ __ ] rogan right of course like
everything is like the end the ending
but if there's anybody that's not
cancelable cancel a bull it's the
biggest
the people with the biggest microphones
and the biggest leash are comedians as a
comedian do you feel a sense of
responsibility to say all right things
are kind of crazy here in america right
now let me i gotta add my like tim
dillon is great at this kind of stuff
like that right yeah do you feel a sense
of like
hey you can't cancel me i'm a freaking
comedian like this is kind of my job
here what are your thoughts on just
overall component of what it's like to
be a comedian and your role in society
see what i'm saying here yeah i mean
totally yeah we are
it's already proven i mean what you just
said about louie being canceled or dave
chappelle being cancelled or to them
trying to cancel joe rogan like none of
that is a thing we did 15 000 people on
wednesday dave chappelle will always
sell out whatever he wants to do anybody
that's ever seen louie unless you've
literally had somebody in a hotel room
jerk off in front of you he didn't lose
a fan
i mean
these you know you can't cancel that
which works if it's not funny that's
different yeah but you you can't cancel
comedians it's just impossible what you
can do
what the one option is is you have to
hope that they get arrested like bill
cosby
is cancelled yeah right but he's out in
all right even though he's free and if
he if he stand up he'd sell out in a
heartbeat he would sell out with his
crowd and a heartbeat a bunch of creeps
bill cosby would 100 sell out in hours
arena whatever trust me so but tony just
said something very important though
tony if you don't mind unpacking that
you said but louis ck got cancelled with
hollywood not cancer so unpack what that
means so he was writing and directing
and producing and acting and those
things you're leaving it into these
corporations hands all of a sudden and
the second that that happens you've
given it and you've given it to them you
know what i mean luckily
you know netfl even netflix was put on
the pressure cooker with the chappelle
stuff it wasn't chappelle who was
getting hurt by it it was them right
because they're going netflix take this
down or else you're against transgender
whatever which if you listen to the joke
there's nothing to even be mad at at all
it's just him covering a subject getting
laughs being actually
a supporter of transgender rights but
nobody listens to anything it doesn't
matter and what they're saying doesn't
matter those people that
the twitter mobs and everything they
don't they don't care at all they're
bored they're always looking for their
next thing
and you know they're always moving on
but getting cancelled by hollywood i
mean he wanted to do that stuff and now
and i know what's going to happen he's
going to make things with his own money
and he's going to make more money
because the next thing that's going to
be the next thing or perhaps the tide is
turning as we're seeing with netflix and
disney and hbo
winning this race because why because
they're they tend to stick with
absolutely good content it's not about
this or pandering towards this i mean
the most watched most awarded show right
now is succession it's the only thing
that i'm really that an ozark right it's
like two of the most
lauded things and it's about what rich
white people making vast sums of money
yeah so like
meanwhile other other shows are like hey
come over here for black history month
or it's asian heritage month we have
these special asian shows and people are
starting to catch on to like why are you
why are you pandering to me because
that's what they think that people want
because everybody's so woke right now
and meandering is the way in our world
in being a comedian that's the lowest
form yeah it's not it's pandering yeah
is trying to oh this is a black audience
so i'm going to sound a little bit
blacker this is worse i'm going to do
these jokes because this this this right
yeah yeah so so that leads me to what
just happened with netflix one one day
okay their stock drops 39
they lose over 50 billion dollars in a
day folks we're not talking like you
know 50 billion in a year and that's a
lot of money in a day
they lose 50 billion dollars 52 billion
dollars but let me read this to you this
article okay so
uh no chill netflix shares drops 39
after massive subscriber loss netflix
tumbled 39 on wednesday extending a
sell-off that has set on set it on a
course for a 60 forgive me 60 billion
dollar wipe out on a market value after
reported sharp decline in subscriber
base netflix stock dropped has plunged
this year you ready this year in 2022 64
shocked wall street by losing 200 000
customers in the first quarter the first
time it has shed subscribers since 2011
it also projected it will shrink by
another two million customers in the
second quarter
so let me get this straight so they lost
200 and they're saying they're going to
lose 2 million
more thou in the second quarter the drop
in the customers has led netflix to
break some of its long-standing rules it
will introduce a cheaper
advertising supported options for
subscribers in the next couple years and
we'll start cracking down on people
sharing passwords even before by the way
can you go to twitter and show what i
just tweeted about netflix a couple days
ago go go to my twitter account if you
can and go lower go lower go lower check
this out you're about to be
shell-shocked keep going lower keep
going lower i love the shirt right there
right there make that
make that bigger check this out this is
twitter this is netflix tweeting this
out wow march 10 2017. love is sharing
your password
and now
you're saying they're going to crack it
down i think these guys completely
forgot
what the hell happened with blockbuster
yeah how the hell did you make your
money yeah how did you make your money
block blockbuster had these late fees
i'd go return a movie and i loved
blockbuster i was i was every friday
saturday blockbuster i love it
and you'd go there and next thing you
know boom you got seven late fees 29
bucks 29 all this other stuff and the
next thing you know you know hey guys
we're gonna have some more late fees
some more late fees yeah
then they're wondering why they're
losing 60 billion dollars and on top of
that the shows they're coming up with
lately right you got one show here which
shows what this is this the show of uh
yeah
[Applause]
i'm curious it came out today yeah today
or yesterday you know what this means if
this came out today or yesterday
millions of people just said we don't
want to watch this 100
100 so so so then the question becomes
the following the question becomes the
following
i'm going to use the example of a
comedian you go up on stage you tell a
joke okay this is how honest capitalism
is and how honest comedy is okay
you go up on stage and you tell a joke
all right
and how quickly if you're testing a new
joke how quickly are you going to know
in an audience of a hundred people your
joke sucks how quickly 10 seconds yeah
you'll know immediately okay how quickly
will you know that new joke is freaking
awesome
immediately okay so now let me ask you
this what if there's a hundred people in
there and you tell a joke and one person
laughs are you gonna tell that joke
depends on how that
they're laughing hard but here's the
point the point is netflix yeah is
telling the joke just to entertain that
one person
what the hell is the matter with you
years ago i was given a sales
presentation and i was 26 years old 25
years old yeah and it was the most one
of the most awkward moments of me giving
a sales presentation so i come in
because i watched the guy do that morgan
i said i'm going to speak like this guy
so i go and i said listen i want to say
something to you guys you know uh we're
doing a meeting this is a very important
meeting that we're having your people
flow out to be here
and uh we have to finish in an hour but
i want everybody to stick around i don't
want anybody to get up and distract
anybody else if you are pregnant and you
need to do that no problem totally
understand but nobody else yeah
so i go on my message 30 minutes into it
one lady gets up and she's going to the
restroom yeah and i said it's okay she
can get up because she had a little you
know little god i said it's totally fine
she's pregnant she's walking she says
i'm not pregnant oh my god
guys
let me tell you it was the most
uncomfortable
i'm like so now try to do this here's
the part
how do you come back from the other 99
people in the room oh right there i'm
saying this has got to be the dumbest
thing you've said on stage 25 27 i
wanted to finish that oh my god as
quickly as possible oh god netflix had a
moment like that yep and they didn't pay
attention to this
and they didn't make the adjustment i
don't understand what the hell they're
going to do is that so it's not the
obviously it's not the password thing do
they realize that it is that what's
happening
are they because i mean the goal woke
and go broke i'm seeing it so much and
it's like you see the writing on the
wall what is going on like what what
you're not you're not seeing the writing
on the wall you ever have you when you
have a breakup with a girl yeah okay or
a guy and everybody comes like just a
friend who comes to you and says hey i
just went through a breakup what's the
first thing your friend's gonna tell you
don't worry about it there's more fish
in the sea and no no no friend's gonna
say she sucks anyway
[Music]
yeah no you know that's that's really
why this relationship didn't work out
right now flip it yeah flip it and say
how many times your friends come up to
you and say so why do you think it
didn't work out i screwed up yeah it was
me it was me it's not really you think
netflix is gonna say it was me my bad
netflix is the girlfriend's fault
there's one person as a business owner
you never blame and it's who yourself so
no no no no
there's one person you never blame the
customer the customer yeah you're right
what are you doing blaming oh it's
because they're sharing passwords you
forgot five years ago you told
them is sharing passwords right they're
losing their identity
so but uh full transparency do you guys
all have netflix
actually like could i be are you being
sarcastic or something i canceled it a
few years ago i'm sharing my sister
veronique's i'm sure she gave me because
i was paying it for myself and i was
like no she's like just get on mine i
think there's there's four of us you
guys are sharing passwords sharing
passwords just so you know there's gonna
be cops outside there you know yeah the
way their netflix is coming right there
i see the cops tyler you got netflix or
no yeah it's a shared password yeah of
course are you being serious or are you
being sarcastic swear to god okay
why would you pay for netflix nowadays
you know so many people yeah
i pay for it but i'm bad with money
i don't pay attention to these things
and i get them and this is what
obviously what's really happening is
their content sucks right now they have
nothing new out yeah everything there's
nothing every you're always one project
away from having another so many
subscribers i mean house of cards was
unbelievable that's what started it
right people are like you have to watch
the show kevin spacey's killing it he's
you can't blank it's unbelievable that's
what happens hbo same thing i mean they
are they are the standard game of
thrones was the most watched thing on tv
uh sopranos was unbelievable you know
they've just they have all the they have
all the awards to prove it but most
importantly they have the people's
you know attention aggression is
unbelievable i'm a byproduct yeah i i
subscribe to netflix
the moment a guy named carl d moss a
friend who i've never met and we met on
facebook and we would talk [ __ ] to each
other politics and my dad said you have
to watch house of cards i love it so i
come home after hearing it from these
guys 50 times i said okay
i'm going to tuscany italy we're taking
like 40 people to italy and the night
before i got a flight the next day jen's
asleep with the baby i go in the room
and i said let me watch one up it's
probably [ __ ] anymore i said babe we
got to get this app netflix yeah so we
get netflix and then i watch one episode
and then i finished it at seven a.m okay
i'm like i i know the next day i slept
on the entire flight to watch house of
cards so you're right
meaning you are one show away from
fixing this but they have to fix it
right but just you can't do this both
you got a great platform great
technology you kicked everyone's ass and
you make this stupid of a mistake
because 0.1 of the audience is
complaining are you out of your mind
yeah paramount plus got me five months
ago they put the new they're so smart
that they put uh the new
the only comedy that i even watch is
south park
and well no it's not but they put one
one hour special they did one thing and
but you couldn't get it on youtube you
couldn't get it on the comedy central
you couldn't get it on the hulu all
these different platforms that they're
on they're so smart they made such a
smart deal i can't imagine what they
gave the south park guys for this but
they go the only way you can see this
episode is by subscribing now to
paramount plus or whatever it is 5.99 a
month however much it was and this is
what they're banking on is that people
are going to
um forget that they're subscribed to the
thing i mean i've paid for five months
for something that i watched for an hour
i don't even i mean yeah it's a gym
membership but
it's gonna ask you something by the way
just let me just say this and then a
question i think netflix is worth 20
bucks a month i think netflix is worth
30 bucks a month i know it's people
going to be like pat you've lost your
mind netflix has so much content it's
worth 20 30 40 bucks a month i paid 125
bucks a cable i pay 99 bucks a month to
netflix so this thing when people say oh
they lost because they raised prices
[ __ ] they didn't lose because of
they raised prices
they started trying to win
and bow down to a 0.1 percent of the
audience thinking that and they screwed
up
people would be willing to pay 90 i
would pay 99 bucks premium to have
certain benefits over anything else i
would pay for it so it's not a dollar
thing that people are bitching about
folks forget just 20 years ago we were
paying 100 bucks cable let me say this
one more time 20 years ago in the 90s
people were paying gladly 100 plus
dollars a month for cable so don't tell
me it's the 12 bucks a month netflix all
this stuff their leadership team has
royally screwed up i'm sorry
if you missed the show it disappeared
yeah you never get to see it again let's
see this is the sickest technology
yeah go ahead well look uh i want to get
your perspective on something not as a
father not as a consumer not as a
content creator but as a ceo because for
as long as i've been doing stuff with
valuetainment for the past few years
we've actually applauded reid hastings
for being such a brilliant ceo right he
wrote a book called what no rules rules
yeah right and we've actually been
singing his credit for years okay so i
want you to put your ceo hat on right
now for a second and ask yourself okay
there's they they clearly are having
some sort of board meeting right now
being like all right guys
during covet 20
they were on top of the world
the subscribership was up bananas
everyone was on lockdown
up until what six months ago squid game
which i never saw was the biggest
[ __ ] show in the history of
netflix everything yeah dude you're the
man you're the best you're the best ceo
ever and now boom just like that their
stock has dropped crumbled netflix has
basically been kind of canceled by the
market so you as a ceo what is reid
hasten saying right now
he's he's got to be having like a
you know a war room conversation with
his team saying guys huddle up you know
he probably has a crisis mode he
probably has a picture of that that
pregnant asian guy and he's like i don't
ever want to see this [ __ ]
again me do what i do here's what i just
did i just went on crunch base
and i looked at who sits on their board
it's the first thing i did okay you got
rich barton who sits on their board you
got timothy haley who sits on their
board since 98 you got jay hoke who sits
on the board since 99 you got ann who's
been sitting there since 2010 you got
ann sweeney who's been there since 2015
brad smith who's been there since 2015
and then you got matthias dophner who's
been there since 2018 and then he got
reed who's been there since 97. okay
do you remember when the whole thing
happened with twitter and everybody was
bashing you know jack dorsey's this jack
dorsey is that jack towards his digits
it's jack i can't believe jack dorsey
you know kicked a suspended or you know
silence trump and jack was kind of like
playing the you know neutral side and it
was oh it's all jack dorsey's fault and
then jack dorsey resigns and boom he
kind of works his way out i think may is
going to be his last one to be an
executive chairman and a new guy comes
in and takes home like oh [ __ ] jack was
actually not as bad as the new guy is
right
the new guy changing him all this other
stuff and now you know uh musk is
talking about potentially buying
uh twitter and in doing so he's thinking
about doing something with dorsey why is
dorsey's name being mentioned again and
some like that so anyways so the point
is i don't know if it's read as a
company gets bigger
you know certain things you no longer
are as involved in especially their
motto if you've ever read their book no
rules rules they'll give you a budget
and they'll say go do whatever you want
to buy and you don't even need to get it
approved by us that's their model like
you can go buy a six and a half million
dollar project and you don't even need
to buy the runner by read and a lot of
their c-suites i love that we're gonna
start implementing that at valuetainment
i really are so funny
so the point is the point is i don't
know how much of it is him right now but
i can tell you right now
you affected people's pockets there are
people who had five million dollars in
netflix stock and you just cost that
person that had five million dollars in
netflix stock you cost them two million
dollars in a day yeah one day two
million dollars and that person is a
tyler mute yourself that person who just
lost two million dollars in a day that
person is not sitting on the sidelines
saying oh it's okay reid they trust you
no no no they're getting emails yeah
they're losing their minds they're
calling their broker then morgan's
calling these guys and goldman's
probably already had a call with them
anybody that's given them money they got
there's a lot of difficult calls they're
going through and typically in
situations like this you have to regroup
you have to bring new leadership team in
you got to fire some people you got to
let some people go they've gone they've
gone through this you're saying fire
people from the board how does that work
not not from the board you can't you you
need to bring some new people to the
board they got eight they need to add
three more because 11 is an odd number
but there's some moves i'd be making if
i was them but if they don't move too
quickly shit's gonna get very ugly and
by the way bank of america is not even
saying to hold so so the market's not
even putting them in the hold category
you know how there's a buy hold and sell
category they're in the cell category
they're not even in the whole category
so people are not even saying it's over
meaning brace for impact it's going to
go lower i didn't say that a lot of the
analysts let me go one step deeper with
you you know how we play that game with
uh with a lot of people okay who are the
most important uh yeah um ceo board
member no no not so much that like uh
universities uh social media how do you
how do you describe that that's the the
most influential parts of society
what is what is the what are the reasons
the top five reasons that that netflix
is it is because they're they they
you know pandered to woke culture is it
because of content is it because of
competition because of paramount disney
and amazon like what are the three or
four reasons that this is happening it
can't just be well their content isn't
that good or because they got a pregnant
guy there's got to be something you know
what's one of the worst things that
happens to athletes to come i saw a
conor mcgregor video i showed yesterday
in front of the guys and when he says
you know people say a loss is really
going to be bad and blah blah blah says
let me tell you what's worse than a loss
that can ruin your career a win
uh when you win you get softer when you
when you show up a little later when you
when you get a little cocky or when you
when you become casual when you win
natural instinct to most people these
guys been winning for too long it's like
how many consecutive quarters have you
been kicking ass you've gotten cocky
you're throwing your weight around
you're like oh we got the grimey we got
the oscars all right
here's who we are and and the market
just said listen bro chill out yeah yes
you're a billionaire yes you got a lot
of money salute for producing a great
product and putting a company that
almost bought you out for 50 million
bucks block blockbuster you put an 8
billion out but this is capitalism
customers comes first and you just
screwed up so it doesn't matter they
royally screwed up because they've been
winning for too long and maybe the best
thing that happened is an l that they
just took
i saw it with comedy central at their i
mean they're still a channel technically
but
they're not famous for their
content their original content now you
know i don't know anything that's on
their network that isn't a re-bought
like they're just running office reruns
now it wasn't that way back in 2009 2010
i was writing on a show called the burn
with jeff ross uh the roast master
general
and um
i remember
sitting at the table for one of the our
first like important meetings that we
had to clean up the writer's room for
there were some comedy central execs
coming in like whoopty whoop and they
came in and i remember at one point
literally uh
one of them said the words because
someone had brought up netflix and in
2009 netflix wasn't really
like it wasn't that big of a deal but it
was coming and i think it was even me
that mentioned like you know netflix
does this thing where they don't have
commercials blah blah blah whatever we
were talking about and i remember the
comedy central exec who is since fired
not a board member yeah a regular
executive someone who's supposed to
decide what gets a second season or what
who we should work with and all these
things and i remember him specifically
saying we are comedy central we are the
comedy go-to on cable
and
people will always come back to us can't
be like that no way this is not how
market works you're in the room when
this happens
he was gone two or three years later
yeah not only is he gone but
and these guys you know again hollywood
they all hire each other's friends i
know he's these guys are all executives
at apple now and here now and netflix
now by the way
because they need people with resumes
that look like they were doing something
but meanwhile they they were sinking the
ship as it was going on they they buried
this show which was hilarious granted
i'm a little bit biased because i was
one of the writers on it but i mean all
these shows that should have been pushed
they hide behind reruns of something for
example you don't get to decide when
if you get picked up you don't get to
decide where your new show goes so
executives are making bad decisions
after bad decisions they debut a new
show but they're putting it after reruns
of this old show
and so by putting you in a position
they're
already deciding that you're going to be
canceled because they're going to go
your viewerships down meanwhile you
could put a shitty show after right
after a good show and they get picked up
because the people are already there
your tb was on the channel so it's
harder to turn the channel than it is to
put it on we talked about this during
dinner with joe about disney if you
remember when when you know a name came
up he's like i know this person i'm not
going to mention what it was but i know
this person i know this person so by the
way somebody just commented in the
comment section so they made me take a
look at this ackman loses more than 430
million dollars in one day because of
that okay so this is this is when it
gets scary because people like this
start calling when carl icon lost money
with aig do you know what carl icahn did
within two months
every day he bullied the ceo until they
had to they had to fire the c under
still have to step down
guys like this have so much power where
they're making these are the guys you
don't want to piss off like you know how
in russia they talk about putin and so
who should putin worry about and what do
they say the family the ugly arcs you
know the the guard all the riches
if they if they say anything you don't
want this is oligarch it's who it is
ackman is part of the oligarch uh if you
if you look at it from that standpoint
but you know you said something and it
made me think about this i've been
processing the understanding of the
meaning of fear in a different way
there's certain words in my life i want
to have i want to have a better
understanding of what this word means
it's always curious about the word lazy
like why are we lazy and you know more i
did i realized okay boredom stems
you know from laziness if somebody gives
a boring joke you're going to become
lazy and your body gets tired great i
want to know what it means to be lazy
but fear
is so confusing because we've been
campaigned with the shirt that we all
wore as kids that said what no fear no
no fear [ __ ] i'm i'm probably
extremely
afraid
let me explain to you what what i meant
by this so somebody's asking me the
question and explaining let me tell you
when i go back and actually pause like
you know how we all say the answer
because the right thing to say and like
is that really who i was yeah let me
think
i'm a pretty scared guy and what do you
mean by that i was so afraid of my dad
dying and my kids never meeting him
because i never met my grandma my
neighbor and my grandpa you have no idea
how scared i was at i would have
nightmares in the middle of the night
it's not fear of oh my god i feared this
but it was such a fear that created such
a sense of urgency for me to get to work
because
now that fear is gone because all my
kids know him so well and they love him
they love their grandpa yeah that fear
is gone now the next fear is i don't
want to walk my daughter down the aisle
and she marries a schmuck at that moment
i've given him up giving her up and i'm
like you're an idiot and she chose to
marry you because daddy made some bad
choices and i was lazy and now i have to
deal with a [ __ ] like you i want her to
choose to marry a [ __ ] because she
chose to marry a [ __ ] not choose to
marry a [ __ ] because he makes 60 grand
a year and he's going to support i don't
want i don't want that to be the reason
from a place of fear right
netflix is not afraid right now and they
should be afraid yeah i think so the
market is not afraid right now right
when you get cocky you lose fear you
have to be reminded you need to get
scared again you need to play scared
netflix is not playing scared the same
one with disney what does disney do
disney comes out and they say what wow
you know 50 of the characters we do are
gonna be part of the lgbt really so you
mean to tell me 50 percent of america is
part of lgbtq community that's what it
is that's what we're going to do in the
stock six months we talked about this it
drops 25 while during that time the
market only dropped 0.6 right and then
what happens this week here's what
happens this week with disney disney
goes to florida and desantis who is
the expert in bullying
does the following this need to lose
special tax status in florida amit
don't say gay clash the boston globe
this usually gets whatever it wants in
florida that era ended thursday when the
florida house voted to revoke disney
world's designation as a special tax
district a privilege that disney has
held for 55 years
effectively allowing the company to
self-govern its 25 000 acre
theme park complex the florida senate
voted wednesday to eliminate the special
zone which is called the reedy creek
improvement district having cleared the
way to this outcome without a formal
proclamation governor desantis will
almost certainly make the measures
official by adding his signature it
would take effect in june of next year
the swift effort to dissolve
reedy creek has been widely seen as a
brazen retaliation after disney's
political donations and the state and
condemned the no educational law that
opponents call don't say gay you know
what this reminds me of the following
let me tell you what happens
years ago uh
elrond hubbard was able to get through
his lawyers to get scientology to get
the tax status as a religion yeah okay
when that happened
it was a fantastic situation for them
because they can take all the money they
want and guess what you don't pay taxes
when i was in l.a our office was in
woodland hills we moved it to burbank
glendale you know why because hollywood
has a contract with tech with california
that they have certain tax advantages in
california to show you what this means
this is like the government all of a
sudden saying scientology is not a
religion you're a business you're
getting taxed this is like the state of
california telling hollywood screw you
you no longer have those tax benefits
that's how big of a thing just happened
to disney just yesterday yep yeah and
the breaking news that he just signed
the bill just love it it's like
fantastic yeah
that was quick yeah
and and i still live in l.a but you know
just for everybody knows i'm moving to
florida asap uh and it's not a joke i'm
serious it's insane how the view of
california the don't say gay build
because that's what people think the
bill's actually called the word gay is
not in the bill at all it's like
education something what pisses me off
the most it's not even the bill because
basically it's saying kindergarten
through i think third grade
nothing about sex nothing about you the
kids in kindergarten you're learning
you're digging and you're like you're a
boy you're
that doesn't bother me you know what
pissed me off the most are the teachers
that were going online and recording
going what the we want to teach like
teachers that were furious because now
they can't teach sex and stuff to
kindergarten kids like the anger of
pathetic leave us alone we still want to
do this and it's just it's it's like you
sound disgusting like you understand
what you're sounding like but but but
the point is the following here's the
point
you have no idea how excited i am right
now i love it let me tell you why i'm so
excited right now let me tell you why
i'm so excited right now
i said this to jose jose and i was a guy
and i were exchanging texts yesterday
was just this has been a special last
four days
i am so excited because in life
here's how this works
you go to a bar
you get into a fight
say you're a tough guy
and you push your weight around you beat
one guy up
oh no you beat another guy up
oh you beat another guy so after a month
or two months or three months you beat
everybody up and you're the tough guy at
that bar there's one guy that's sitting
in the corner quietly yeah he ain't
saying [ __ ] yeah
and then one day you pick on him it's
over and you pick on that guy and then
you realize
you're officially not the toughest guy
in the bar yeah you're gonna get your
ass handed to you he's going to publicly
embarrass you
i was in the army
and we in our boot camp we were all
fighting okay and it was a circle and we
would that's how we get rid of our
testosterone we're fighting so i'm
fighting and i'm be and i have no
cloutified i've never done have i've
never done mma nothing i'm not a take on
nothing
i'm just yeah so my nose has been broken
one too many times right right so i'm
fighting up i'm gonna lose you so i feel
so good i'm like oh look let me tell you
who i am
so the reputation i got right
a guy shows up in the circle there's 200
guys that are wanting to fight and one
by one
guy shows up he's five six five seven
yeah maybe 130 pounds he says do you
mind
i said what do you mean he said i'd love
to fight you oh great i said i don't
want to hurt you yeah of course
so and this is before ufc so you didn't
know who knew how to fight back nowadays
you don't want to fight because anybody
knows how to fight for sure if they say
do you mind you shoot
do you mind
something that's the scariest
but you got no felix can't fight anybody
phyllis just talks [ __ ] and we have to
fight for felix no
this guy comes and he says can i fight
you we fight let me tell you took him
six seconds what ethnicity was he no no
he was a
uh he was a black uh
guy 18 year old black kid like me and he
was from florida or ohio yeah and i say
in all of them bam i'm on the floor i'm
like dude
so what does it matter with you he says
i'm the florida state champion in high
school so why don't you tell me
something come on this is why i thought
it would have ruined the surprise
so i said listen man this is great we
became good friends what can i get you
so the point is the following in life
you're eventually going to realize who's
out there today the market is starting
to tell you stop bullying us
people are waking up elon musk is fed up
and he's done with these bullies and now
he's bullying bullies good guys like
rogan are bullying bullies
guys like bill maher are sick of it bill
think about bill maher is sick who's
bill maher
i sent something to jon stewart two days
ago because his show did you guys hear
about john stewart's show yeah he's
reading what i said to jon stewart on
twitter john stewart's show comes out
and they he tanked they only have 40 000
listeners
and he sends a tweet
he sent right to read his tweet he says
holy [ __ ] just think how bad actually
click on his tweet and then go back
because you have to see what he's
tweeting holy [ __ ] just think how bad
it'll get in season two and they uh
upped our episode order wtf right and
it's the he gets 40 000 viewers and then
here's what i said john you're one of
the best to ever do it if not the goat
however here's some feedback if you're
open to it carry on if you're not i feel
you have a unique voice i feel the
market is filled with those on the left
and or right who are 100 loyal to their
party and not america click on us i can
read the rest of it yeah click on that
go below it
i said i feel 20 percent of the market
who was in the middle is sick of it the
40 on the left or the right who doesn't
think the other side gets anything right
we both know that's not true and semi
arrogant to believe that take a comedian
entertainer like yourself russell brand
joe rogan bill maher dave chappelle and
a few others who use comedy to take
shots at people on both sides of the
aisle what gets annoying is when they
you only pick on one side and play
politics loyal to the people whose
birthday parties and functions you
attend i believe you have an opportunity
to help unite america bill maher has
gained new audience because he's calling
out his own side you hesitate to do that
for some reason it could be fear or
comfort zone or something else not sure
you were the goat of the original
political satire of interviews you
cornered people stephen colbert tried to
be you but he missed the mark bill maher
has gained a new ton of followers
because he's shown he can reason he can
call out bs so much as you may not like
this message but maybe taking a bit of
responsibility and owning up to it could
change the game not selling out stay
court your values and principles but
strengthen them by seeing flaws in them
they may not be 100 right again carry on
if this was a waste of your time to read
i was perfect there you go there you go
i see some of these guys and i say dude
maybe you're wrong yeah and guys like
him only have forty thousand five forty
thousand listeners how the hell do you
realize rogan rogan has if we do them at
forty thousand times sentence four
hundred thousand times a hundred four
million
rogaine has three hundred times more
listeners than jon stewart
not three times folks
300 times more than jon stewart
just because you're worried about those
parties you're not 100 it's pathetic to
me how much do you think jon stewart is
kicking himself or giving up the daily
show for whatever this thing is i don't
even know what the hell that is but even
who's the noah guy i mean trevor noah
barely barely talks uh talk [ __ ] like i
think i saw one clip where he was
actually like you know joe biden's you
know messing up and hope trump i can't
believe he actually said it but like you
said to patrick uh
when i see bill maher now i'm like whoa
is he shifting one of my cousin mike was
like i think he's shifting because he
knows nobody wants to listen to your
[ __ ] a lot of people are right
have any of your friends from uh
the right gone closer to the left
anybody right of center going farther
left oh jesus
no no no no listen to what he said i
agree with him people who were on the
far right who have gone a little bit
more left yes i agree he's not saying
they went from right to left
he's saying you were far far right and
let's just say you were
right of mega yeah and you're kind of
like yeah i'm kind of going to be a
little bit more here and i'm going to be
i don't know pick a name i'm going to be
more like desantis or i'm going to be
more like this so i have seen that
happen where people are making that
shift yeah but a lot of people who were
on the far left have gone to the left oh
yeah and now in the center slightly
right yeah that's the part i'm almost
seeing like if this is the pendulum
some people are going and they're kind
of going here
people are trying to i saw something the
other day they had i can't even remember
the article but they had rogan's face on
with ann coulter and desantis and trump
and something and i'm literally these
people right-wing crazy like he's
he is an la
liberal i mean that's what he was at
least uh you know what i mean like it's
all
it's always so there it is yeah it's
that one msnbc
with these people because he's a
right-wing hate monger well that's what
they're saying there which is why bernie
sanders i can't believe that the
washington post they cancelled lives of
tick-tocks yeah they canceled it let me
remind you this is the guy that endorsed
bernie sanders yeah for president of the
united states and now he's a
right-winger because uh he's big because
he has the most successful show and adam
libs of uh tick-tock is just uh uh it's
really tweeting that's right they make
videos themselves retweeting uh teachers
that are speaking in front of a camera
in their own house or their office and
this she's just reposting it and they
canceled her is that is that insane and
then the same girl that wrote this
article went out on cnbc and cried
cried on air because she had such a hard
time because people were doxing her yeah
and there were mobs and what does she do
she goes to this girl's house
right to her family's house starts
banging on the door
and then proceeded to dox her and reveal
her identity
and the girl who ran the account is now
in hiding yeah she put her address in
that she did exactly what that's
thinking this is what i'm trying to say
to you this doesn't work man no you
can't bully for too long
somebody really shows up and then you
have to really straighten up your act
every kid learns this some learn it at a
young age some learn it at a teenage age
but every kid learns
some companies it takes them a while to
learn a lot we start off as a small
insurance company we had 60 agents and
we grew now we have licensed 35 000
agents 20 000 active agents and we've
grown but every day i'm still you know
there's there's got to be that fear of
even though you got this this market
it's competition you can't be arrogant
about it a lot of these guys are getting
arrogant about it by the way did you see
jinsaki crying yeah on that podcast yeah
i did she was did you see that or no
dude she wasn't she crying she was
crying because of the go ahead
she was crying uh because of the
desantis the law being put into the
thing where that you can't teach she's
thinking it's the most messed up thing
that you can't teach she's again she's
saying that it's it's anti-you know
anti-gay she says how can you do this to
kids who are going through this and if
they want to be trans you have to let
them be in and then she starts crying
says you don't know how much this hurts
me and i'm like i'm like i'm watching
like wait what my buddy tim dillon had
the best take on that i can't remember
the exact tweet but it was basically
like uh it wanted that he quote tweeted
one of these teachers that was like how
am i
not supposed to talk to if i ever if i
tell my students that i had a wonderful
weekend with my gay lover like how why
would i not be allowed to do that
um and tim dillon goes you know that's
cool and all but
my the everyone knows that all the best
teachers are like this mysterio these
mysterious figures you didn't know
anything about him they came in with a
ratty jacket and ratty hair
and
taught you actually learned [ __ ] they've
never talked about their personal lives
you didn't know what kari drove you
didn't know he lived yeah and you didn't
know his first name right
no mrs williams she's in she's out but
yeah yeah and then what was the what was
the kicker to that but that's it it was
just that you know sometimes his takes
are more brilliant than they are you
know hysterical but that was it it's
like it really got me to thinking like
yeah what are we talking about here why
would you need to know your the personal
lives of your teacher
on any level not to mention i mean it's
just ridiculous i don't know about you
guys patrick i the only time i learned
about sex as a child and i remember the
room i forgot how young i was it was
just a slideshow quick of the male body
parts the female body parts it was
awkward everybody was kind of you know
giggling that was it bro it was up to
our parents but you know middle eastern
parents there's no birds and bees it's
just like you better figure it out on
your own but it was one day in class why
why the anger what bothers me is the
anger of why can't we teach them what we
want it's like bro relax let the parents
teach their kids about sex and and honey
there's you know think about dude
kindergarten you know how confusing it
is just to be a kindergarten like
they're they're kids trying to feel like
you're a boy but you could be a girl but
you could change it on thursday it's too
much information for a child bro wait
wait down the road they're gonna trust
me they're gonna see it if they're
watching netflix i'm expecting they're
gonna see it when they get older you
know what i mean yeah the kids used to
figure it out on their own when they
when you saw the picture of the male
genitalia either you felt something in
your belly
or you didn't because or when you saw
the female
genitalia you're like oh something about
that i like
exactly you didn't yeah like there was
no they weren't like here's what to do
with this yeah exactly okay let me let
me and you could get rid of yours i'm
gonna throw you guys a completely
different angle here with that i
actually really enjoy
that these people are trying to force
these beliefs down people's throat
because what's happening right now i'm
not saying whether you're on the left or
on the right is that at the end of the
day common sense is prevailing of course
and at the end of the day people are
like i don't know about this bro like i
don't
why is it like any i don't care what
side you're on anytime you just like
what what's going on like that look
whatever that looks like just like what
that thing
it's not adding up it's not making sense
and i and and and whether you
were on the on the left and you didn't
see what you saw what trump was doing
you're like i don't know about this or
you're on the right and you're just a
common sense person and you're seeing
this don't say gay stuff and this disney
stuff and you're just like
you're it's a losing proposition at the
end of the day
common sense is what people yearn for
yeah and great what they gravitate to
and if you're on the side of like
pandering to your point tony of to like
a small segment of society you're gonna
[ __ ] lose yeah right but it's it's
just it just boggles my mind how and i'm
not i'm not right on my left i'm just in
the middle how this side this presidency
this administration they had
talked all that trash trump's gone right
they had all this time to at least pick
somebody they went with joe biden
whatever he's a familiar face 81 million
votes i still can't believe it you had
all this time to make a stand and change
and really make a difference what have
what have they done and i hate when
people just say infrastructure i don't i
don't care about infrastructure
everything is going wrong nothing is
going right you had all this time you
talked all this [ __ ] about trump what
are you guys doing and nothing and
they're just with [ __ ] like this like
the the white house gensake is furious
and crying because it's not cool not to
teach these kids about sex in general
they're going to pay the price for this
i mean there's you're seeing i mean i
see it let me tell you let me tell you
what's going to happen
okay
this is so ridiculous how idiotic they
are when it comes down to strategy
there's two different ways what's the
saying would you rather win the battle
or the war the war okay these guys are
all winning battles let me explain
the more they do this okay the more they
play this game and pushing whatever down
kid's throat
every pastor in church right now
is going to be using that message and
grow attendance you're right because
here's how pastors gonna use it they're
gonna say
how many of you are sending your kids to
public school if you're sending your
kids to public school and you're worried
about the values and the principles
there's never been a more important time
to plug your kids into a church
because the school's not going to do it
so their stupid ideas and philosophies
is going to help the organization they
least want to know exactly and number
two all this [ __ ] they're feeding a
parent who's sitting there who was okay
doing what they were doing now they're
saying now my kids are gonna go to
christian private school or private
school that's catholic or private school
that's whatever that's teaching strong
values and principles i'll bust my ass
to make that additional thousand dollars
to send them to private school private
schools are going to go up public school
are going to get their assets handed to
them home schooling is going to go up
they don't realize how strategy and you
know war works
it doesn't work the way they're doing it
they're idiots i'm telling you i believe
that they're ideas i'm seeing it short
term they will win
look what the santa is how do you think
disney's board is sitting right now
sitting saying guys 50 since 19 so for
55 years we've not paid any taxes the
hell did you guys just do it we went
walk by the way do you know how much
money that is that's insane do you know
how much money that is oh my god you're
not talking about like a couple million
you're talking real money millions
that's called stupid that's what it's
called dumb stupid yeah you made certain
things you said that is stupid and you
had freedom and now you don't yeah now
you're paying a price for it but what
they said the other day like they're
going to stop calling kids boys and
girls
they're going to only call kids dreamers
and fairy bells or whatever the hell
that is
boys and girls is this
and i i think tony i want to all you
guys honest opinion i think personally
that that whole
she he the them that started because the
generation i think one or two after me
hitting your kids became taboo because
you know this if i went to my father and
he's like vinnie come here and i was
like excuse me dad has a middle eastern
father and i went it's he them they or
whatever he would be like they are
moving the [ __ ] out of this house today
like it's i'm not saying beating your
kids but that generation where you can't
even talk
or be like listen relax chill like
because now it's it's just free falling
i saw somebody that was like they sh it
was the on certain days it was them she
and i'm like if you think i'm going to
[ __ ] take the time to be like what's
today and what are you i i can't bro
that's why i'm moving out of california
i i have i have two emotions right now a
ton of excitement and confidence and a
ton of fear which combine it together
produces urgency yeah that's what it
produces beautiful and i'm good with
that yeah i want whatever that produces
elon musk twitter investment could be
bad news for free speech you guys saw
this on wahpo right yeah just real quick
for your daily dose of irony right what
does that first line say
elon musk just bought a three billion
dollar stake in twitter because when
you're the world's richest human you can
toss billions around like that yeah who
the [ __ ] owns the washington post yeah
uh beth baseball
the second richest person in the world
you can never
how many guys know how how the poison
pill works you know the poison pill that
everybody's saying wow they're gonna use
the poison pill you've heard of poison
pill but do you know what that actually
means i love you
so tom and i were talking about this and
tom made a very good point about the
poison pill here's how poison pill works
so they're sitting there they're saying
it's a defensive strategy by a target
from to prevent or discourage a
potential hostile takeover by acquiring
a company okay so they want to prevent
uh musk from taking over
twitter now
twitter stock is 40 some dollars 42
dollars when musk says i'll buy it for
52 it's like a number like that that
you're saying right
so if you
had a million dollars of twitter stock
okay somebody offered to buy it for 20
higher today and it's not worth it yeah
and that didn't happen how much did it
cost you two hundred thousand dollars
right so the boards using a poison pill
to not
allow musk to buy well let's see what
happens say they succeed okay and they
don't let musk buy it yeah musk is going
to sell his 9.2 percent that he
originally bought from twitter
twitter stock from 42 what is it going
to drop to
to 30 to 25 now watch this
if twitter stock drops from 42 dollars
he offered 52 yeah if it drops from 42
to 25
do you know what happens to the board
the board gets a massive massive
lawsuits from shareholders do you know
why because every uh board's
responsibility is who shareholders
you're responsible for shareholders so
this poison pill is gonna backfire on
twitter again
they're playing they're trying to win
the battle which they will they could
and musk is playing the war exactly he's
going to win the war they have no clue
what they're pretty much doing is the
following here's what they're doing
they're going to get their asses handed
to them then they're going to get fired
then they're going to save elon musk 20
billion dollars because ilan is going to
buy it for
20 billion less than he is today you may
as well take that money today and let
this guy do his thing so this even this
poison pill strategy
is going to be one of the most publicly
embarrassing situations for them so this
is why you trust capitalism and you know
that eventually when you bully people
there's going to be people showing up
that bully the bully and and uh patrick
and all this all this for him to make
the platform someplace where you
everybody can have their opinion because
you guys all know this one side is
winning the i don't care what anybody
says they're winning that that canceling
and your your voice cannot be brought
back how many uh things were taken down
just because you know you know fact
checkers and some of the factors like
the guy from uh reuters the owner of
reuters sits on the board of pfizer so
you know what i mean it's isn't that
like a
conflict of of interest when you're on
the board of fact-checking [ __ ] that
people like trying to ask questions
about pfizer that's
what i mean it's way it's way too much
man just wait by the way did you see
what dorsey said about brian stelter can
you pull up that tweet reliable sources
no i i
don't know if you guys saw what dorsey
said about uh brian stelter so
uh so can you make that bigger so i can
read that so brian stelter says tucker
carlson always selling the same thing
uh he is selling doubt
and then jack responds a minute later
and you all are selling hope oh god
that's hilarious that's from jack wow
then everybody says [ __ ] jack is
defending tucker and he continues not
defending the thing i'm holding up a
mirror beautiful is what he says right
so think about for jack to say that to
brian stelter
i mean
jack is supposed to be
part of that camp so then we all know
what happened with cnn plus let me read
some of these statistics to you folks
here's what happened with cnn plus cnn
plus will shut down april 30th just one
month after launch okay
this is a 300 million investment that
was lost warner brothers discovery has
decided to shut down cnn plus just weeks
after its launch this is not a decision
about quality we appreciate all the work
ambition and creativity that went into
building cnn plus an organization with
terrific talent and compelling
programming right
chris lake chairman seo of cnn worldwide
said but our customers and cnn will be
best served with the same simpler
streaming choice one of media launched a
standalone
new service less than a month ago on
march 29 it garnered less than 10 000
active
viewers in two weeks after its launch
the company said customers will receive
prorated refunds on subscription thank
god but 300 million dollars was lost
with the launch and they brought chris
wallace from fox imagine he doesn't have
a job right now pissed off he has to be
he was at fox for 20 years and he left
for cnn plus yeah well and did you see
any of the content they had like don
lemon cooking with his mom on facetime
and the there was no wi-fi so you
couldn't even see her uh
uh who's a white hair guy anderson
cooper anderson cooper was in his
kitchen and he's like i'm gonna do this
segment but my kids sleep like it was
just horrible
kim kardashian marriage to former
basketball player chris um for 72 days
last two and a half days you're messing
with me buddy this is what you're doing
that's hilarious that's hilarious did
you did you did they show it like uh
does john do you have that up or no um
300 million dollars cnn plus wow lost
this don lemon first of all is there
anybody more boring than i hate he's so
boring yeah have you ever tried
listening to him i
in the gym you know all the gyms in l.a
it's cnn on every dude it's it's torture
when you're running it gets me angry
because they plaster it on everything
and it's just him sitting there judging
and talking [ __ ] about everybody i hate
that guy i really hate him
he wha what part of florida are you
moving to so fort lauderdale hell yeah i
love it yeah me too texas was on the
play but what do you mean me too i know
i know i like that this these are my
places i met the governor i met ron
desantis last uh saturday at the ufc oh
great
him and rogan met during in like the
middle of it there was like there's like
a break between the
espn one the part and the when they
switch over to pay-per-view we have like
seven minutes yeah and
so rogan and me and his crew cam hayes
and all these people we jetted to this
green room that they had
cornered off with desantis and his
entire like 40 percent
people came with them was it for yeah
i'm sure it was like the florida secret
service or whatever they got
anyway and um
coolest guy and literally pitched he's
like you guys need to move to florida
whenever whenever you guys are done with
your texas when that when when stuff
hits the this the fans coming down there
yeah we'll be waiting for you did he
really try to recruit you guys
who's your governor abbott yeah dude how
boss is that guy he took all the buses
of all the uh illegals
he bust them to
started arriving today and there's
people with umbrellas
they were taking selfies of like the cap
it was [ __ ] brilliant what was uh the
sanders sales pitch you said you had
seven minutes with them but what was
that that was just yeah we want you here
um and and uh i go i said i love the way
that you handled uh the pandemic man
beautiful awesome
and he goes yeah who would have guessed
that you give the people the choice to
do what they want to do would work in
america brilliant ways said it i mean i
fell in love with this guy for the rest
of our lives he'll get any vote that he
ever runs for from me that's it common
sense and for some reason
that's what we seem to be like lacking
nowadays right a bunch of weird [ __ ]
happens meanwhile anybody that has any
common sense at all and that guy is just
common sense
uh he's
he's going to walk into the white house
i think he's going to he's going to
stroll in i don't know
well
he's got to win the republican primary
you don't think he will
there's some guy there's some orange man
looming over the republican party right
now let me say let me say ah i was going
to say i would rather have and this
person i would rather have desantis
because dude trump lover may hate him
it's a little too much bro and people
and
mind you they're gonna have to dig up
dire on desantis what what are you gonna
what collusion what all that what are
you gonna do he's he's a golden child
he's the one by the way but you gotta
you gotta be very careful
on how you sell him
because
if you sell him as the golden flawless
everybody has [ __ ] yeah of course some
is going to come out on the game yeah
yeah and market has to be ready there is
desantis has got uh stuff in the closet
so if you don't get a ton i don't know
if it's going to be as legendary as a
stormy and karen mcdougall type of stuff
because that guy took it to a whole
different level
you know but here's what just happened i
had a uh um
ah okay so i had a conversation with kid
i can't tell you who but i had a
conversation
and you're giving me the oohs and the if
if if
uh uh trump runs desantis is not running
i i mean it's less than a five percent
chance he's running if trump trump goes
if trump goes desantis is not running at
all is trump is the word in the street
that trump is going 99 he's right
that means because he's not going to be
the vice president so
so so that means
he's going to wait till 2028 not 2024.
so this is what that means now so some
people that are saying oh my god this is
if anybody's ever thought about moving
to florida yeah that means desantis is
going to be the governor until 2028. so
that's a very big insurance policy
for anybody that is thinking about
moving to florida because by 2028 that
gives them six more years to find
somebody to replace
him because that's the key you gotta
also find somebody to replace him but if
trump runs which there's a 99 chance
he's running he's not going to be
running but there's a there's a problem
with him waiting that long right now
he's hot he's how many
of course we agree but i'm just telling
you
he does not want to go face off because
he knows trump's going to talk [ __ ] and
he's going to talk
santa is not going to just sit there and
tell him
do you think if trump was trump won and
trump was still in this
woke i mean because the old movement's
been going but all the stuff that
they're they've been trying to pull and
all that stuff would it be happening or
it would not or i mean he would be
bodying these people on twitter and out
in public speeches i think people forget
exactly how funny yeah hilarious he was
the funniest one i mean and it's like he
again he's another guy that love him or
hate him i mean was calling out this
stuff before everybody i mean he's
literally not on twitter anymore yeah is
that crazy but they're crazy like
there's people that are like in on isis
and [ __ ] that's spoken tweet it's funny
yeah vladimir putin's on twitter 100 and
donald trump isn't yeah yeah 100 and so
there's a reason for that you know
someone that doesn't want him talking
about all of this
that is their agenda period so
i mean that's everything that's why this
elon musk thing is an actual thing
buying twitter no because of that it's
the blatant thing that he's going to do
it's obvious it's all about free speech
so how could he
keep a former president banned that's
how possible what's the what's the
chances that if musk
succeeds and this poison bill doesn't
work that trump gets back on oh i think
100 okay yeah i think that's the
statement he's going to show exactly how
he's going to show exactly how free free
speech is do you realize here's the
following thing
if
he buys
twitter
at 52 bucks
and he lets trump on twitter stock will
go to 200 100
by the way it's just a prediction
i'm just telling you brilliant it's
gonna work he buys
52 bucks is underpriced with musk owning
it
i think twitter stock has the ability
from 52 to even 10x within a five year
period
so that's that's just a possibility of
what could happen
look at how much they were quoting
twitter twitter was the news for those
four years here's what trump said today
it was them yeah reporting about twitter
trump will be back on tweeting 40 times
a day oh my god
yeah
the greatest troll of all time we'll be
back on again he's the ghost by the way
uh
podcast
how hard is it to succeed in a podcast
game is podcast game a hard game
would you say podcast game is a hard
game if you love the podcast that you're
doing then it's not
okay if you if you corner yourself into
right if you corner yourself into
something that my friends always are
like i am tony i'm thinking about
starting a podcast i think i'm gonna do
you know cooking with uh comedians or
whatever you know that's not even an
example but i'm just saying like if you
corner yourself into
any type of pocket i think it becomes
miserable you know i i look i you know
i'm friends with joe and i see what he's
doing and not only is he
um you know killing it but he gets to
interview whoever he wants and talk
about whatever he wants for as long as
he wants to talk about that full control
and uh people are into it obviously his
listenership keeps going up every time
they try to cancel them he gets more
listeners more viewers it it's it's you
know well let me ask you a question and
he knocks it open he didn't paint
himself into a corner any rogan episode
he could be talking to a fighter he'd be
talking to a comedian he could be
scientists
but but imagine if let's just say a
person let's make this person up
let's say there's a person out there who
is very well spoken
he's got 132 million followers on
twitter okay let's say he even becomes a
two-term president
and then let's say he starts a podcast
with another guy whose name is bruce
okay who's a very famous singer okay and
they signed a 25 million dollar podcast
with spotify okay
a year later
spotify drops him
can you see that happening with somebody
that big
i mean that's pretty crazy for that to
happen but that's what just happened to
barack obama
why spotify dropped its deal
with barack and michelle obama tyler can
you go up so i can read this entire
article because this is almost
unbelievable make it a little bit bigger
so we can read this the obamas are
searching for a new home for their
podcast after spotify reportedly
declined to offer the former first
couple a new contract because they
didn't make enough personal appearances
on the stream and services brock and
michelle obama reportedly in talks with
several companies including amazon
audible and i heart media on deal that
will likely be worth tens of millions of
dollars according to bloomberg news the
ex-president former first lady who
co-owned the production company higher
ground will reportedly decide on their
podcasting platform of their choice
sometime within the next few weeks
higher ground is said to be in seeking
an agreement that would allow it to
release uh shows on several platforms
simultaneously one of the sticking
points is in negotiation with spotify
and the swedish company instance uh in
insistence on an exclusive licensing
deal which they didn't want him to give
because they want to syndicate it
amongst everybody even if the obamas
produce podcasts for another company
those shows will in all likelihood make
their way to spotify anyways streaming
services want to about want uh the
obamas to make more frequent appearances
themselves in order to generate more
buzz for the company but the former
first lady reportedly willing to commit
to
no more than eight episode programs
higher ground was paid 25 million
dollars after signing with spotify in
2019
so only eight episodes is what they want
uh spotify is moving on
power move is this a smart move on
spotify to drop them a president who's
got a
very strong audience his wife wrote a
book that sold 30 something million
copies you know whatever the number was
that she made 36 million dollars would
you say this was a good move on spotify
or a bad move on spotify
i think a good move tell me why yeah
because uh
spotify cares about actual listenership
and subscriptions based on what they're
paying for
and even though he has a lot of twitter
followers and she might sell a lot of
books
you you have to bring them to the
podcast world you know what i mean so
you know rogan's signing with spotify
and having a built-in audience of a ton
of podcast listeners is
different and much much much more
valuable than having a politician who
gave many public speeches and has
twitter followers like
a lot of people a lot of people have a
lot of twitter followers a lot of
comedians and they and they suck at
selling out shows they can't fill a
venue
yeah and they tweet all the time and
they work on their following and they
post videos and all this stuff
but if you suck live you suck live and
they're not going to get any better at
podcasting doing eight episodes every
year we know this right you naturally
get better at what you do they don't
want to do it they're literally clearly
there for the payday yeah for sure and
so um yeah what they should be doing is
just episodes for free and putting it
out everywhere anyway i mean if they
wanted to get good at that thing but
they're not going to get good well
that's not going to get winners if they
if they did if he did podcast him and
michelle the podcast twice a week
and they went one year straight do you
think they'd kill it yeah
i do as well if they did it how often
twice a week twice a week yeah
at the beginning the article says they
did it how many times twelve times what
a year whatever
yeah i mean they're they're what is it
called you just kind of like mailing it
in or packing it in you're just kind of
you're not you're not putting in the
work obama is broad
did you guys see they brought him to the
white house because
biden's numbers were taking so much it
looked like a rock star was in the white
house
joe biden was behind and like trying to
chase him and every it's just dude
everybody will watch him every single
day pat let me ask you i mean you're a
businessman you're focused yep okay
we've done this is number one what are
we 140 what is this
not to mention the x amount that we 148.
holy [ __ ] and not to mention the dozen
or so we did back in dallas under a
different name
if you were only doing this
once a month
12 times a year yeah
how
what kind of bang for the [ __ ] listen we
feel it if you don't do it for a week
yeah yeah you feel it if you don't do it
for a week podcast game is a lot of work
it's it's but you have to do it steadily
but
i wonder with spotify spotify to give up
uh uh uh i actually think they made a
very smart move because
obama's have to have their show on
spotify and spotify doesn't have to pay
them [ __ ]
they just have to be like what are you
talking i'm not gonna pay you nothing
you're gonna put it on here anyways
because you have to mess with my
audience yeah okay but the reason why we
were willing to pay rogan is because he
agreed to be what exclusive
if you're willing to do exclusive we'll
pay you 25 and you do one or two
episodes a week but if you want to be
able to put this everywhere why the hell
am i going to give you money i'm going
to give you [ __ ] yeah and i think that's
the right move they made good for
spotify spotify you said something
spotify is in the business of getting
listeners you talk such a logical way
you said that's capitalism yep yeah i
don't mind giving you money okay i'll
give you money but you got to bring me
listenership exactly you do great here's
what we'll pay you and tony said
something pretty funny before the
podcast he goes how many people do you
know that said hey did you catch that
latest obama podcast yeah
if you're in the comment section has
anybody ever listened to one of the
podcasts and if you've listened to all
of them comment below i'm actually
curious obama hillary what's it called
the obama
[Music]
it's obama and bruce springsteen
i don't know should be much bigger than
it is regardless i think i think so
should it though i don't know i you know
obama and bruce springsteen you don't
think you type icons don't don't say it
because you don't like his politics it's
obama let me tell you i think obama has
the i don't know that bruce springsteen
has the pool but i think i don't know
about people
i think people like michelle more than
they like a barack i think people are
over barack i think they're done with
them they're sick of him they're saying
800 million dollars library he's
building in chicago they saw the 800
page
[ __ ] autobiography
this is the far end proud boy tyler
that's talking right now
get back to the normals
i think people saw exactly what barack
obama did to the country i think they
saw how he divided it and destroyed it i
think they saw that race relations were
at an all-time high before barack obama
took office i think they saw that he
said trayvon martin could be his kid i
think they see well through barack obama
i think you're absolutely wrong i think
that by the way that's the on the right
side of things those 80 plus million
people that would love to listen i don't
know why they aren't i don't think it's
absolutely wrong i think you're 20 right
i think there is 20 percent that he lost
but i do think there's a big like if if
i'm sp let's just say valuetainment and
obama is agreeing to do podcasts with us
exclusive
and he's willing to sign a four-year 25
million dollar year contract with me and
he's going to do two episodes a week and
a heartbeat i'll sign a 25 million
dollar contract with obama for four
years for two episodes a week but him
and his wife live
right here 25 million bucks what do you
want to do i'll give you 25 million up
front and another 75 million over the
next three years you want to come on
let's do it he's going to get the
eyeballs period it's obama he's young
he's sexy he's attractive he's got an
audience not an audience that you would
kick it with but he does have an
audience that's the key barack if you're
listening pat just made a verbal offer
towards you do you think come on down to
florida do you guys think spotify would
pay how much do you think spotify would
pay joel biden to be on the podcast with
his wife how [ __ ] funny minimum wage
minimum wage he would just be trying to
shake people's hands i don't even know
it's like john dude that'd be so funny
that's not him though he at this point
of the game everybody knows that's
he got he became president for different
reasons it's a whole different situation
that's about to get very became
president for one reason it's just that
he wasn't trump that's no basically
that's it i i okay no you're you're not
yes but at the same time listen
strategically america made a stupid
mistake
because
during 9 11 everybody got behind america
yeah and the enemy was outside of
america during kovid
instead of making china the enemy which
would have brought the entire country
together yeah america may trump the
enemy trump wasn't the enemy they're
idiots just so you know that they're
idiots what they did
whether you agree or disagree that was a
stupid move because
yes you got him to get out of office but
you also divided america so you may have
done something well we figured out a way
to get rid of that guy we've impeached
him 17 times who gives a [ __ ] people now
they're thinking other people are
enemies just because they have
differences together it's a very stupid
move made by america i don't i don't i
don't think that was the right movement
and you still can't say like we're not
holding china accountable because
apparent let's all be honest with each
other it definitely came from there it's
still people are still like that's kind
of racist if you're saying that it's
from them like no no it's not like
people are right now saying i would
listen to anybody okay so let's touch
the erp i want to respond to you i
listen to anyone on ppd but obama right
okay
uh
i would love to have obama on here to
ask him some real questions not because
oh my god we have obama obama no i want
to ask obama some real questions to see
what he contributed to
and what because remember when he said
some he said something a few years ago
says listen if you can't pull your pants
up and you're going and doing this and
you don't have the money to do so you
know you're broke like i don't know if
you remember this when he said this like
three four years ago
that's a statement to community you know
so so i think there's a part of him look
when you start making money
and you start really making some real
money your decisions change you start
realizing taxes
just for the hell of it i'm not for it
you know i remember when dave chappelle
got his first big payday
and uh obama was raising taxes on the
first term
chappelle's like dude this is the first
time i've made six million dollars can
you just wait one more year before you
raise the taxes right
but even chappelle was like dude i don't
want to pay that additional 600 000 so
working hard making money gets you to
realize on certain things with taxes by
the way a couple people commented i do
want to say something on what one guy
said to you about you tony sonny baldwin
gave 20 bucks and he says i didn't know
who tony was
until the leaked video now i patiently
wait for mondays hashtag kill tony ooh i
like that those are my favorites hell
yeah he gave you love with your uh show
which by the way why don't you tell
everybody about what you do on a weekly
basis with your podcast
big crazy stand-up comedy live show in
front of a big sold out live audience
and i give uh people starting out or
maybe someone that just wants to
you know get sort of their a little bit
of a big break um a chance i pull names
out of a bucket and if i pull a person's
name out they get one minute
uninterrupted to do their stand-up
comedy on a stage while me and my guests
sit at a table and then they stay up
there for about anywhere between five
and 15 minutes afterwards as i interview
them and ask them questions about their
life find out more about them so it's
like a super spontaneous crazy all
improvised
uh stand-up comedy meets regular podcast
podcasts where anybody can sort of be on
it and people get a chance it's sort of
like uh
i don't know
america's got talent meets a podcast but
only with stand up and it's super edgy
so so big warnings there we push it to
the uh to the limit what's been your
most memorable moment because i've seen
a bunch of them i know that you and bill
burr kind of got into something at one
point i don't know what's like the most
memorable least memorable examples yeah
somebody clipping that out of context as
well uh but you know i mean so many tons
there's just i'm just looking at that
russell peters okay alex jones joe rogan
ron white yeah bobby lee
uh theo vaughn yeah we've done like what
is it like six hundred we're up to you
we're at six almost almost six hundred
and you just do them on mondays yeah
yeah yeah yeah we've been doing them for
how many years now eight years over over
eight years almost nine years but we've
also done a bunch all around the world
we've sold out theaters in london and
dublin ireland and all over australia
all over any comedian gone on just for
the one minute and now eight years later
they've blown up and they're massive now
any household names uh
oh my goodness so many first of all all
of my people that were that i made
regulars there's always a few regulars
at any given point and they write and
perform a brand new minute every single
week they're all working now every
single one of them from hans kim the
newest regular all the way to
i mean everybody's just a full-time
comedian now ali makovsky uh sarah
weinshank kim kongden william montgomery
david lucas all of these people are um i
love it doing their own shows i love it
i saw that i've signed i've seen a few
shows i'm like i love the format the way
it is it's guy gets up for one minute if
you're able to hit it great if you're
not you know it is what it is you got a
minute to do do we have callers by the
way john if we got any colors let's take
a couple callers here for the podcast by
the way tyler i just saw your socks very
interesting socks good for you those are
my rocket socks wow so i'm like so
impressed with you man that's so
impressive those obama socks yeah i see
obama on there obama podcasts
michelle
right
very impressed just so that i could step
on him man we have a couple calls go for
it we have a gus on the line what a name
this is a first time gus how you doing
uh fine uh everything's cool uh big fan
of your show by the way also shout out
to adam but anyway my question is
i know this is like old news but louis
ck just won a grammy do you think that's
a sign that he could come back to
hollywood or is he gonna be treated like
a harvey weinstein type individual you
know but i hope everything's all right
what do you think about that i think i
think that is uh the uh beginning of i
think it's the foot in the door without
a doubt because uh he's getting respect
from someone something over there is
like uh
did he get charged with a crime you know
these things
when the smoke clears sometimes you also
have to remember that a lot of people
that uh
that it looks like maybe they got
canceled maybe
they're selling more tickets than ever
maybe their viewership is up maybe
people went and took maybe even the
haters
um went to find something else to be mad
about and what are you gonna do if
you're sitting there watching louie and
you're not laughing you have a dog [ __ ]
sense of humor
so uh i mean you're you're literally not
funny you don't know what's funny and
[ __ ] that you laugh at stupid because
louie is truly one of the best in the
world it's completely undeniable nobody
doesn't like him nobody can't laugh at
him
um so yeah what's good is good same
thing with rogan's podcast people think
he's being canceled
his listenership keeps going up yeah so
oh yeah you know the the people that are
like i'm gonna go find something else
i'm gonna find a clip that makes me mad
they end up getting addicted to
long-form conversation all of a sudden
instead of listening to pink floyd on
their drive to work every day they're
listening to joe rogan because they're
into that format now they get hooked and
uh louis does good work so does joe
people that do good work will continue i
mean look you say wines is he gonna be
treated like weinstein people even
though he's not getting the money and
sold or whatever people are still
watching all those weinstein movies i
just watched goodwill hunting yeah every
time you watch a tarantino film a lot of
your favorite movies the matrix
a ton of them
uh he made so like you can cancel you
can try to cancel a person but you can't
really cancel their work
do we have any other callers that you
want to chime in john yes eric is on the
line eric how you doing
hey i'm doing great thank you so much
for the opportunity on the show
and my question is uh can we trust elon
musk with owning twitter do you think uh
he will push his own agenda like jeff
bezos does with the washington post or
will he stay true to his statement of
freedom of speech i think he absolutely
will push his agenda but i trust his
agenda more than the current agenda
everybody who buys a business there's an
agenda
when you take a girl out you have an
agenda
your phone call today came with an
agenda
our podcast has an agenda kill tony has
an agenda the current administration has
an agenda nobody here is naive
but uh his track record of creating
businesses and finding ways to do things
better
uh i trust more
than i do everybody on social media
agreeing together right now all the
major social media platforms all follow
by the same guidelines all of them do
they all follow and drop drop everybody
to get one platform owned by a guy like
elon musk that's not going to be doing
that
uh i think that's that gives everybody
competition and scares the crap out of
them which is something we need today
john do we have another caller
good question we have victor on the line
why they don't have pulp fiction on
there who's who's is this somebody's
messing with we have victor on the phone
victor how are you
i'm doing all right how are you i'm i'm
good man what's on your mind
no i was just curious um i'm i follow
the markets pretty closely
and
i'm sorry i'm a little star shocked here
my man
so you follow the markets quickly
closely
i'm sorry you said you follow the
markets closely
i follow the market pretty closely i
i've done my own studies on it and what
i'm curious to know about your opinion
is who do you think is going to show up
in the big short too
who do i think is going to show up in a
big short two meaning like who's going
to be the modern-day michael burry or
who's going to be
the aig's of the world or the woman in
the world that went from being worth 330
to 1.9 billion bought by chase like
which one are you talking about
uh what was that second part i missed
that you know how wamu used to be a big
bank and it was competing with everybody
and then chase came and bought him for
1.9 billion two years after being valued
at 3 30 on forbes
or lehman brothers or bear stearns yeah
like who's going to crumble next is that
what you're asking
yeah pretty much like um you know
there's people that bet against the
economy there's people that that with
the economy but
who is going to come out on top
who's going to come out on top
those who have a real business that's
making real money
so
like you know all these specs that went
out of business and
the spac model like eighty percent of
the specs are not even worth looking at
because there's not really a proven
business within the spec
are you following that victor or did you
john did you just drop him
he's still on okay so you know the
family
victor or no
victor are you familiar with spax
yes i'm sorry i'm having a hard time
hearing okay then then so if you know
what happened with spax you would know
what's going on the fact that those that
don't have a real business model are
gonna get their asses handed to them i
think private equity is gonna take a hit
i don't think we have too many no income
no asset stuff right now people that are
buying homes you kind of got to have 10
or 20 percent in there they're not doing
the kind of 100 financing that was being
done back in the days in the 2000s
i do think some of the banks are gonna
take big hits but not the way they took
it before but these guys that are
playing you know all in money into the
market without a real proven
business model they're going to take
hits a lot of nft companies are going to
take hits
uh there's going to be a few of them
that are going to make you that are
going to do well but most nft companies
are going to take a big hit but anyways
i can go on into that a little bit more
john do we have any other callers that
have a question for
tony victor thank you for the call do we
have any other questions for tony uh no
we don't there's a wrap for calls okay
sounds good so what i want to do is the
following this shirt here
free will that i have on okay if you can
see this obviously it's not about free
will it's about freeing will smith this
started with the conversation that we
had
uh during dinner which was a bet i think
there was a hundred dollar bet that was
made if you remember you and joe rogan
we made it we made a bet and the bet was
what within 12 months
there's going to be a divorce or there's
not going to be divorce right right
you've said that there is going to be a
difference i i bet on the hundred
dollars being that and rogan said no i
said no one's willing to take me on this
but he says i'll bet you let's bet a
hundred bucks right so
so you and robert joe rogan threw down a
lofty 100 dollar bet well i think he can
afford it and i'm gonna i'm gonna show
you that i can afford it as well but
here here's the point
the point is while we were we were
having a conversation for me it was more
from the standpoint of
that video that came out with jada and
jada bullying will and will say social
media is my bread and butter i don't
appreciate what you're doing right now
and she says you can tell now why we
have issues in our marriage
i think
jada's a bully
i think jada smith pinky jada pinkett
smith is a bully and she's bullying will
and i think this guy
has been
sitting behind closed doors do i think
he's done what he's done and had a lot
of fun one million percent do i think
he's done some stuff that's broken
jada's heart one million percent do i
think there's a possibility that jada
has said and used the following words
that if you do anything i'm going to
tell your darkest secrets to the course
of course i'm leaning towards yes yeah
100 i think there would be a red table
conversation throwing will under the bus
maybe i don't know i think there could
happen do i think it would be playing
the victim card you don't know how
difficult it was being married to will i
think so do i think will win on
charlemagne the god the what is that
show uh uh the killer breakfast club and
charlemagne asked him a question saying
hey how does it feel knowing jada will
never love you the way she loved tupac
yeah and he asked the question of will
do i think that bothers them yes do i
think the market seeing what happened
with augustus at augusta what's the
guy's name
obviously yeah so do i think that
bothers him on how the market sees him
yes do i think jada maybe has something
on him with
challenges with maybe men and he had
certain things that he did with men over
the years i think there's something
there but i think the guy
almost needs to be given permission to
call it quits and move on and he's
afraid to do so so that's why the
hashtag freewill to say will buddy if
you're going through it man somebody
needs to talk because i can guarantee
you here's a challenge somebody asked
joe and i were having a conversation
about have you ever talked to a friend
about having to get a divorce remember
how that conversation went
because i've had those conversations
with a handful of friends but it's only
been a handful of friends and the
conversation goes like this and by the
way
sixty percent of the time when you have
that conversation it backfires on you
because here's how the conversation goes
i had a friend of mine i pulled them
aside and i'm like dude
uh
how do i explain this to you
you are an alpha
i've known you for many years you've
always been an alpha but you've turned
into a beta and i look at your face you
hate it because you've compromised your
own values and principles
and it feels like every time i talk to
you're walking on eggshells it feels
like you have handcuffs and shackles
right now and you don't know what to do
next
and i just want to tell you from the
outside i'm not the only person that
notices this okay you need to make a
decision i've had this type of
conversation with men and women before i
get to this point i want to push therapy
i want to push as much go places go do
stuff together but every once in a while
get to this point right
out of the five conversations three of
them guess what happened to it
the individual goes back and tells who
great the wife and and after they tell
the wife what does a wife do don't you
can never talk to patrick you can never
talk to patrick again so the phone gets
broken you're done yeah right
okay
but the other two
went and processed it
and one of them took the lead in the
family read a book called no more mr
nice guy
and the wife actually responded to him
and said you know what i've been waiting
for this and they've been happily
married till today the other one went
and had the conversation she was not
having it he left her okay
i think
i wonder how many people who are friends
with will have the audacity to give that
advice because they know it's going to
go back to who her
and if it goes to jada what do you think
jada's going to do to that person okay
so so think
you know one time a guy and i were
having a conversation i said listen a
friend of mine i said look why is it
that everything i talk to you about you
go tell your wife it's just my wife i
said do you think that's how it works
yeah yeah so let me get this straight
what book tells you that everything you
tell me you have to go tell your wife i
said do you think everything you tell me
i go tell my wife he said well it's your
wife aren't you supposed to do it i said
no that's not how life works yeah why
what's your biggest concern here's my
biggest concern if me and tony are
homies and we're buddies we're best
friends he's married i'm married
he confines in me in something
i go tell my wife three years later my
wife and i get a divorce hypothetically
what's her loyalty to tony this much
yeah did you understand what just
happened is this much loyalty that she
has to tony she doesn't sit there and
worry about what tony's career is going
to be right it's my loyalty to him that
i just lost tony so now tony doesn't
feel comfortable talking to to me
i'm convinced
there's a web
that will is in man i think she has
videos of him getting pounded by dudes
there has to be something
dude
in it for the black man the name of the
video men in black oh man
well played
stupid
i actually have one real idea that i
think needs to happen
because what i'm getting very sick of is
these a-list hollywood alpha men getting
emasculated by women
right now the two biggest stories in
hollywood right now
are freaking will smith and jada smith
and johnny depp and amber never heard of
never heard okay and i think what needs
to happen is they need to sit down in a
room and have two mirrors and one seat
in the middle of the mirrors okay and
leonardo freaking dicaprio needs to say
welcome to the room gentlemen no uh we
are in a very elite company right here
we are the biggest a-list stars in the
freaking world and you i want you both
to look at a [ __ ] mirror yeah you're
a will smith yeah you're johnny frickin
them
like just look at them and remember who
you guys are you could do whatever you
want yeah you own the world you're worth
hundreds of millions and you're just
getting emasculated by these women
taking your money and taking your pride
follow my playbook here for a second
gentlemen you don't have to not get
married out of kids yeah but be a
goddamn pimp yeah maybe i'm doing too
much stuff with freshman fish and rolo
these days i don't know shout out to
those guys
but man up will smith yeah man up uh so
man up but but but here's the thing let
me tell you what what
if you you ever been in a web have you
ever been in a relationship like that
with a woman where you felt like you
have you ever because i've been have you
ever been in of course okay
when when you're in it
how oblivious are you yeah you are like
you almost have to be out of it to
notice it yeah who do you know that
hates will smith prior to the slap in
the face and what happened with his zero
you tell me who you've ever met that's
ever hated well
nobody beloved i mean beloved is an
understatement american legend american
legend for a guy to come from his
background and build a story that he's
built people forget fresh prince of
bel-air all these movies he's done all
these major films he's done and he's
going through this so so here's what
we're doing folks if you want to support
this this is what we're doing if you
want to wear this shirt to start the
conversation and post it you can buy
this shirt i'm being serious with you
you can buy this shirt at free
will shirt.com am i saying it correctly
can you put the website so people can't
see it you can buy
freewheelshirt.com we're selling it for
29.99 a hundred percent of the profits
is going to national institute of mental
health
100 beautiful of the profits you can buy
this and free will pick your size 30
bucks go all the way to the bottom go
all the way to the bottom go all the way
to the bottom go all the way to the
bottom press no thanks click on that
link national institute of mental health
whatever we sell we're sending all the
money there because i do believe
i do believe will is having certain
mental challenges right now and i'm
telling you i'm convinced his therapist
his friends everybody's afraid of jada
and somebody needs to have this video be
shared with them for him to say you know
what yeah you know i i don't like why
you you know people are talking like
this or he's gonna say maybe this makes
sense okay and by the way yeah i'd love
to see it work out i just think it's way
past the level of it working out it's
time for tomorrow
joe thinks he's going to live unhappily
with jada for at least longer than a
year he cannot do that though he's such
a special guy i know but it's been it's
already been a long time you know what i
mean guys like that sometimes they get
in too deep he's he's one was you said
it best you surrounded by yes man what
was the date of that
what did i know because it was early in
april this was early april ufc
jacksonville whenever we got it
ufc and adam you could see his soul like
in that video where she's recording him
you could see his soul is just april 9th
i love that this whole thing started
with a dinner uh
group dinner with yourself first of all
four o'clock what's the name of that
restaurant do you remember cal fort
steakhouse wow the owner sent me as a
big fan of the contest in jacksonville
unbelievable unbelievable by the way the
wait what was the waiter's name i wish
we could give him a shout out man that
guy is a man she was like the guy spoke
like john bernthal good i kept telling
him you sound like jon bernthal he had
the right voice the name of the place
again calford
c-o-w-f-o-r can you please i'd like to
give these guys a shot i'm starving
right now
by the way
this was in jacksonville i would not
have expected at this quality restaurant
bone marrow okay fogra
oyster any it was the most high quality
we had
anyways it was insane amazing yeah
highly recommended and the owner's even
a classier guy
on what they're doing fantastic places
i'd love to go there tonight but it's a
long drive
anyways gang listen
if you agree with what we just talked
about in regards to will just start the
discussion
talk about it wherever you want to talk
about it and if you sport the shirt
other people are also going to talk
about 100 is going to go to
national mental health institute is
where the profits are going to go but
last but not least before we wrap up
tony you're performing tonight uh what
are you performing tonight miami improv
two shows and two shows tomorrow and uh
yeah i'm on a big tour going up to a
bunch of places tony hinchcliffe.com for
tickets and if you're not following his
show
uh on youtube kill tony if you just type
in killtone you'll find it it's
hilarious the format is great uh if you
haven't seen it and then our brother
here vinnie oshana future looks bright
stay tuned we got some big things here
coming soon when when is our next
podcast what do we have going on today
rick massey monday diamond dallas page
tuesday love diamond dallas page and
paul manafort on thursday paul
manafort's thursday next week that's a
pretty heavy list this week wow holy
moly okay folks have a great weekend
we'll see you guys on monday take care
bye bye bye bye
you